Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja nicht nehme ich gleich mit, weil ich einfach doch mal mitkommt.
Und das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bäm!
Hbat du Erfahrungen mit Valken?
Ne.
Hab ich nicht.
Mit Vulca..
Vulkan!
Nein. Keine Ahnung.
Ach geht das wieder? Ok, nice.
Heute machen wir wieder was, wo ich
keine Ahnung von hab.
Gucken, ob ich das auf die Reihe
krieg. Besse...
Beste.
Beste... Beste Nemo's hier.
Mal kurz das Sound ein bisschen leiser machen.
Wir müssen heute langsam, wir müssen heute entspannt anfangen.
Ich hab grad Sportstells gemacht, dann hab ich Fressenstells gemacht.
Äh und davor hab ich A-Stells gemacht.
Muss ich erstmal ein bisschen, erstmal ein bisschen ähm...
Wie nennt man das so schön? A-Klimatisieren, ja.
Was auch immer das heißt.
Ja ich weiß, am 30. Juli war der Suisse-Admin-Day, aber...
Ich würd mich gar nicht mehr so sehr als Suisse-Admin sehen und außerdem...
Wäre es viel besser, man sagt seinen Turnschuh-Admins ab und zu mal,
dass man ihre Arbeit zu schätzen weiß, anstatt da auf einen Tag zu warten.
Was machst du für Sport? Zu wenig.
Kill für 7 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Leute, soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Ich hab's ja gestern schon gesagt im Stream, aber es geht weiter.
Die Leute unter dem New-World-Video triggern mich.
Die lösen mich hart aus.
Die lösen mich hart aus, die Leute, das ist schlimm.
Das ist wirklich ganz schlimm.
Jetzt hat irgendwie einer so nen einseitigen Aufsatz geschrieben in 3 Kommentaren,
warum ich kacke bin.
Beziehungsweise keine Ahnung habe und ich hätte doch warten sollen mit dem Video.
Hallo, ich sage am Anfang des Videos, ich hab bis Level 12 gespielt,
es ist der 2. Tag der Beta, das ist also kein Fazit.
Ne, das Video, was ich vor 2 Wochen zu New-World-Beta gemacht hab,
ich sag das 20 Mal im Video, mindestens, wenn es mal reicht.
Aber die Leute checken es einfach nicht.
Die lecken alle Critical Information.
Abgehört, dass manche der neuen RTX-Grafikkarten durch...
Das stimmt so nicht.
Also das Thema hatten wir schon mal am Anfang.
Mittlerweile ist es ja ein bisschen abgeschlossen.
Also ich würde New-World da nicht die Schuld geben.
Ich würde in dem Fall ganz klar dem Grafikkartenhersteller die Schuld geben.
Wenn du eine Grafikkarte mit den offiziellen Schnittstellen verwendest,
dann darf sie nicht kaputt gehen.
Auch nicht, wenn du sie 100% auslastest über 2 Stunden.
Das Problem ist, warum das bei New-World eingetreten ist
und bei anderen Spielen nicht.
Normale Spiele lassen eine Grafikkarte nicht dauerhaft zu 100% aus.
Die müssen immer mal wieder auf CPU-Input warten
oder irgendwelche anderen Slowdowns, was auch immer.
Ein normales Spiel hat selten wirklich max-out 100% GPU-Auslastung.
Was die bei New-World verkackt haben, ist,
die haben im Launcher keinen V-Sync angemacht,
beziehungsweise die haben im Launcher so schnell gerendert, wie es geht.
Und nachdem man saumäßig viel am Anfang in New-World im Launcher hing,
weil die Server zu voll waren,
hat es bei manchen Leuten die Grafikkarte überlassen.
Aber das ist eindeutig Fehler der Grafikkartenhersteller,
dass sie das Ganze nicht ordentlich getestet haben.
Es ist sogar in dem Fall gut, dass New-World reagiert hat
und gesagt hat, okay, wir drosseln das standardmäßig im Launcher.
Das ist ja auch sinnvoll.
Niemand braucht 5000 FPS im Launcher.
Aber es ist nicht die Schuld von New-World,
dass die Grafikkarten kaputt gegangen sind.
Das habe ich jetzt schon an vielen Stellen gehört.
Das ist aber, wie sagt man so...
Urban Legend ist es nicht, aber...
Wie nennt man das so?
So Noob-Legend, keine Ahnung.
Das erzählen immer nur Leute, die denken, sie wissen es,
aber sie wissen es eigentlich gar nicht.
Also ich bin der Meinung,
New-World hat nichts irgendwie verkehrt gemacht.
Die benutzen die Grafikkartenschnittstellen,
so wie es gedacht sind.
Aber es ist natürlich doof.
Volle Pulle zu rendern im Launcher, im Hauptmenü vom Spiel.
Aber das ist kein Fehler in dem Sinn.
Also das ist kein Fehler, der das kaputt machen darf.
Du testest auch immer eine Produktion.
Ja, wer macht das nicht?
Wer macht das nicht?
Ich dachte, das ist best practice.
Also in Zeiten von continuous integration
und continuous delivery und continuous deployment
wird es selbstverständlich in Produktion getestet.
Alles andere wäre nicht agil genug.
Nee, ich sag ja auch nicht, dass du einer der Noobs bist,
die das erzählen.
Du hast es ja in Frageform gestellt
und nicht so nach dem, wie ich weiß, wie sie ist.
Also wie gesagt, das denke ich dazu,
dass New-World keine Schuld trifft.
Es gibt übrigens überhaupt keine Probleme.
Also wenn du eine ordentlich gekühlte Grafikkarte hast
und wenn du Vizonk einschaltet, gibt es eh kein Problem mehr.
War das jetzt ernst gemeint?
Na ja, teilweise ist es doch so.
Natürlich, ich meine so Sachen nie 100% ernst.
Aber gewisse Wahrheit ist ja da nicht abzustreiten dran.
Ist das Testing?
Testen braucht man nicht.
Das ist genauso wie Sourcecode kommentieren.
Das braucht man auch nicht.
Wenn man gute Programmierer hat, die gut programmieren,
dann ist der Sourcecode so, dass er sich selbst dokumentiert.
Und dementsprechend muss man ihn auch nicht testen,
weil es vollkommen klar ist, immer wie er funktioniert.
Nein, das meine ich jetzt nicht ernst.
Aber das davor meinte ich ernst.
Das davor meinte ich zumindest zu einem gehörigen Anteil ernst.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit,
wo der Trend dahin geht,
eher kleine Dankeschön für den Sub, Vivian Miali.
Vivian Miali?
Wie auch immer.
Aber auch danke für den Prime Sub.
Excellent Subscriptions.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, oder?
Sekunde und kurz gucken.
Passt doch 1 zu 1 gut.
Oder? Musik ist zu 1 nice.
Aber was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit,
wo so der Trend ein bisschen dahin geht,
dass man eher, also nicht überall,
bei mir auf der Arbeit, das ist kein gutes Beispiel für,
aber der Trend geht ja eindeutig dahin,
dass man nicht mehr 2 fette Releases im Jahr macht,
sondern dass man eher sagt,
man macht kontinuierlich kleinere Features,
die dann aber auch mal ab und zu in die Hose gehen können.
Natürlich im optimalen Fall ist das alles wunderbar,
continuous unit-tested, continuous integration-tested,
continuous usability-tested und was auch immer.
Kann man continuous usability testen überhaupt?
Keine Ahnung.
Hab ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Geht das? Wie macht man so was?
Doch, ich weiß, wie man das macht.
Leute, big brain time.
Continuous usability-test.
Du machst über die Pfeifer-ARP.
Pfeifer hat bestimmt nach wie vor ein bisschen
ein bisschen mehr Zeit,
aber Pfeifer-ARP, Pfeifer hat bestimmt eine ARP.
Du machst über die Pfeifer-ARP,
beauftragst du, immer wenn der Build-Step
in deinem Build-Tool fertig ist,
beauftragst du über die Pfeifer-ARP 5 Inder,
die das für dich testen und ihren Reporter zu schreiben,
und erst wenn, sag mal mal, 4 von 5 Reports okay sind,
dann machst du weiter Deployment.
Das ist doch eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Das sollte man machen.
Das braucht man auch gerade, ja?
Das ist der Nix.
Wisst ihr was, wenn ich das auf der Arbeit vorschlage,
ich wette mit euch, es gibt ein paar,
die das für eine gute Idee halten.
Das muss ich mir bezahlen lassen.
Big brain time.
Does Pfeifer have an...
Pfeifer hat keine ARP?
But it's not public.
Was ist hier los bei Pfeifer?
Es gibt bestimmt Leute, die es nachgebaut haben.
Pfeifer-ARP, ja.
Unofficial Pfeifer-ARP.
Python.
Oh, 0 Sterne.
Na gut, dann muss man irgendeine andere
Crowdfunding-Plattform suchen.
Wobei, man konnte...
Leute, ich hab noch eine bessere Idee.
Noch eine bessere Idee.
Man braucht überhaupt keine
Pfeifer-ARP.
Man generiert den Report,
den schickt man einem Inder,
und der macht auf Pfeifer
Aufträge an weitere Inder auf.
Und dann...
Ja, das ist das, so muss
es eigentlich machen. Wozu soll ich den Kram
selbst programmieren?
So sollte man, so
sollte man das machen, ja.
Und dann machen wir continuous
usability-tests mit
Pfeifer-Intern.
Chat, ich würde sagen,
wir sollten ein neues Startup gründen.
Ich hab auch schon...
Wir brauchen für unser Startup
eine Punkt-Io-Adresse.
Gibt es...
Code-Quality
ist zu langweilig.
Crowd ist gut.
Crowd-Test-Punkt-Io
oder sowas.
Gibt's das? Gibt's bestimmt schon.
Oh, jetzt hab ich Chat neu geladen, Leute.
Bam!
Das ist es. Das ist unser Startup,
Leute. Crowd-Test-Punkt-Io.
Gibt es
Pfeifer-Punkt-Io?
Hahaha!
Ernst?
Leute, das hat doch einer von euch.
Das gehört doch euch.
Gibt's zu. Das gehört dem Chat.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Who is?
Das gehört dem Chat. Das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen.
Continuous-Crowd-Punkt-Io.
Leute, die Idee finde ich richtig.
Ich muss mal aufschreiben.
Punkt-Io. Crowd-Test-Punkt-Io.
Das finde ich eine super Sache.
Das geht automatisch über die Pfeifer-Appi.
Moment, Moment. Pfeifer...
Ich muss mal den Who is machen,
dem Pfeifer-Punkt-Io gehört.
PlayerD, wem ist...
Change...
Was?
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich hier gelandet bin,
aber ich geh mal lieber wieder runter.
Schau mal, gibt es sogar von Amazon?
Amazon?
Was?
Echt?
Das ja, die haben bestimmt eine API.
So, ähm,
heute, heute, heute, heute, heute, heute, heute.
Heute greifen wir nicht,
wenn ich kurz Abos hab.
Heute machen wir ein bisschen Prograstells.
Aber ich muss erst mal einen Who is machen
auf Pfeifer-Punkt-Io.
So, das muss jetzt mal schnell sein.
Pfeifer-Punkt-Io.
Auf Pfeifer starten.
Bäm.
Also, Who is
Pfeifer-Punkt-Io.
Namecheap. Ah, okay, okay.
Ja, man bekommt ja heutzutage
kaum noch was raus über
über, äh, äh,
Dingsregister-Geschichten.
Das ist ja alles
mittlerweile anonymisiert.
Und wenn es nicht anonymisiert ist,
haben sich die Leute mit Fake-Daten registriert.
Ich hab alle meine Domains mit Fake-Daten
registriert, alle.
Ich heiße dann Peter Wubbles
oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja,
Tromm, da hast du recht.
Ich hätte auch auf irgendeiner Porn-Seite rauskommen können,
aus Versehen. Aber was ist jetzt
dieses Codewords? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich geh da jetzt auch nicht mehr drauf.
Wer weiß, was da los ist.
Aber Crowd-Test-Punkt-Io finde ich gut.
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Du kannst ein Report
hochladen, was die Leute testen sollen.
Dann Crowdsourcest das automatisch.
Crowdsourcest das
über irgendwelche anderen Plattformen
an Inder und Chinesen.
Und du musst dann dort die Reports
wieder, das ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Cacw.io
CacwCoin,
Alter, wirklich.
T resolution
Es gibt alle möglichen Coins mittlerweile.
Gut, also sehr gut,
beste Startup-Idee
schon wieder in Stream hier.
Wie stellst du da die Qualität sicher?
Gar nicht. Muss ich auch nicht.
Alternative wäre gar keinen Test,
da wäre noch schlechter.
Ich, also die, die, die Devise von Crowtest.io ist, äh, alles ist besser als gar kein Test.
KegWu gesichert.
Ja, ich seh schon, mein Chat hat die halben, die halben Twitch-Emotes an, äh, Punkt.io
Domains schon.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass Punkt.io, äh, ne Top-Level-Domain ist, die irgendeinem Inselstart
gehört?
Punkt.io ist keine, ist keine Domain, die irgendwie, ähm, was mit Technologie zu tun
hätte.
Punkt.io ist, ähm, äh, die, die ist, ist, ähm, Moment, hier, Punkt.io gehört britischen
Territorios im indischen Ozean, das ist, das ist irgendwie so eine Chagos-Ashi-Peel, was
auch immer.
Also Punkt.io Domain hat überhaupt nichts mit Input, Output und Technik zu tun, das
ist irgendwie eine Inselgruppe, der das normalerweise gehört.
Und die jetzt rummeckern, dass sie die Rechte an dieser Domain für das Apple und Knife
verkauft haben, nichts mehr von, ähm, was kostet eine.io Domain nicht so viel?
Als haben wir uns irgendwann mal angeguckt, ja.
TV ist genauso, ja, ja, ja, richtig, richtig.
Leute, Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich hab Rider registriert jetzt, ich hab jetzt das, äh, Jet-Prains-Desktop-All-Versions-Nee-Moment.
Ich hab mir Ding, ich hab mir das jetzt gekauft, das da hab ich mir gekauft.
Das All-Products-Pack für ein Jahr, mit allem, was, was man so kriegen kann von denen.
Java, Stealth, was ich nie benutzen werde, Rider, Seal, also was ich da, ich mein, ich
verwende davon das da, das da und das da.
So, das da könnt ich mir vorstellen, wenn ich Pysonsachen muss zu verwenden, das da
hoffe ich brauch ich nicht, äh, Ruby mach ich nix mehr, Webstorm vielleicht noch.
Was sagt ihr denn Leute, meine Frage an die Leute, die das benutzen, was sagt ihr denn
Wishl Studio Code versus Webstorm, was Frontend-Sachen angeht?
Also ich hab Webstorm nur ganz kurz ausprobiert und hab jetzt den Vorteil nicht so richtig
gesehen, aber vielleicht gibt's ja da noch mehr.
Heißt Rider jetzt nicht Wichs, also es hat ja schon so ein Bart, äh ja zumindest, ich
mal gucken, ob sich das lohnt, also es ist auf jeden Fall billiger als drei Produkte
zu kaufen.
Das kostet im ersten Jahr glaube ich 250 Euro, im zweiten Jahr, what the f, persönliche
Nutzung.
Hä, wo ist denn das Ultimate Pack, wo ist, ah hier, das, genau, 249 Euro, 199, 100, also
ganz ehrlich, das kann man schon machen, das ist, das ist echt okay, guck mal, das ist,
das ist der Jahrespreis und du bekommst alle Desktop-Produkte von denen, also und wenn
man das ja auch verwendet, im, sag mal, im professionellen Umfeld, dann, dann macht sich
das ja auch bezahlt.
Also das kannst, also ich finde, du kannst echt nichts dagegen sagen.
Ja und genau, im zweiten Jahr ist es ein bisschen billiger, am dritten Jahr, am dritten Jahr
kostet es nur 150, also da kannst du dich finde ich echt nicht beschweren.
Da wird der Azubi Programmierer arm, also für Studenten gibt es kostenlose Versionen
glaube ich, wie es mit Azubis aussieht, weiß ich nicht, aber als Azubi würde ich ganz
ehrlich, da würde ich die Firma fragen, ob sie mir das sponsort.
Da kriegt man genug Stuff fürs Geld, sehe ich auch so, Bettge, weißt du was, Chainlord,
wir machen das jetzt.
Wo habe ich es denn, wo habe ich es denn gespeichert?
Wo, Bett, hm, wo, wo, tja, wo habe ich das gespeichert?
Wo ist Wupp Bettge, wo habe ich Wupp Bettge gespeichert, Wupp Bettge, Desktop, nein Desktop
ist es nicht, ja, dann laden wir das nochmal runter.
Wupp Bettge, Copy Image, zack, nein Copy, Copy Image Address, zack, Wupp Bettge, Save
As, Wupp Bettge, mach das jetzt rein, muss der Chainlord nicht länger warten, aber ich
brauche das Emote auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen, bisschen hübscher, äh, warte mal,
wo geht das jetzt hier, Inhalt, ich finde das neue Twitch Zeug extrem unübersichtlich,
Einstellung, Partner, Emote hinzufügen, zack, Wupp Bett, Wupp Bettge, soll ich Wupp Bett
oder Wupp Wupp Bettge, was sagt ihr, also entweder Wupp Bett oder Wupp Bettge, wie soll man das
nennen, Bettge oder, Bettge, ok, hochladen, so, es ist drin Leute, Wupp Bettge ist am
Start, da ist es, sehr gut, exellent, Wupp Bettge, guck mal so langsam, aber sicher haben wir
doch sogar schon eine ganz gute Emote-Auswahl hier, bin immer noch begeistert, dass Twitch
endlich animierte Emotes hat, ja, ich habe immer noch 5 Slots oder 6 Slots frei, gut
live, danke schön für den Sub, das ist eine gute Idee, gut, also, ich mache kurz die Musik
ein Ticken, leiser, auf geht's, also was wir heute probieren werden ist folgendes, ähm,
also, das, das Auferlay Tool, also, Moment, Moment, ich muss anders anfangen, also, ich
habe hier so ein Tool programmiert, mit dem ich Bilder anzeigen kann, das habe ich normalerweise
auf dem zweiten Bildschirm aus, aber so sieht das aus, ne, da kann ich hier Auferlay Bilder
und Sachen anzeigen oder GIFs mit Sound oder so abspielen, so, das Problem ist eben, dass
der GIF-Player, den ich verwende, saumäßig schlecht performt, guckt euch das mal an,
ich klick das jetzt an, Achtung, klick, und jetzt kommt das Bild erst, so, und jetzt
habe ich hier, in letzter Zeit haben wir mal einen GIF-Player programmiert, der etwas schneller
funktioniert, also, der ist instant, ist instant da, so, was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe,
wenn das Teil anstatt GIFs normale Videos abspielen könnte mit Sound, da könnte ich
so einen Schwachsinn wie den hier direkt als Datei hochladen und musste nicht ein Sound-Datei
machen und ein GIF, weil das GIF sieht auch noch scheiße aus, und ich habe ehrlich gesagt
absolut keine Ahnung, wie man mit FFmpeg Sounds abspielt, also, wohlgemerkt, nicht einfach
mit FFplay, das wäre ja easy as fuck, sondern wirklich per Low-Level einlesen, Sound abspielen,
das probieren wir heute mal aus, ich habe absolut keinen Blas und Schimmer, wie das
funktioniert, ich mache einfach mal ein neues Konsolenprojekt, wir testen das aus, es kann
auch sein, dass es komplett in die Hose geht, ich weiß null, wie das funktioniert, dass
der playchamp, playchamp.io, also, ich werde heute mal versuchen, Sound abzuspielen, und
zwar, ich habe mir schon ein Testvideo hierhin kopiert, und zwar mein letztes, wo ist die
Lautstärke-Steuerung von dem Kack hier, warum kann ich die Lautstärke, alter, diese Windows-Programme
sind zu schlecht, so, das versuche ich jetzt abzuspielen über FFmpeg, so, das wird wahrscheinlich
aus mehreren Teilen bestehen, also der erste Teil, den wir machen müssen ist, das kriege
ich noch hin, Datei einlesen, eats, da weiß ich, wie das funktioniert mit FFmpeg, FFmpeg
Video decoden, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, wie das funktioniert, ich vermute mal, wie
Video decoden, keine Ahnung, so, und das nächste ist, Sound in Windows abspielen, wie das funktioniert,
weiß ich nicht, wir werden da wahrscheinlich dazu eine Library verwenden, entweder N-Audio
oder CS-Core, ich bin mir nicht sicher, was ich davon schon mal verwendet habe, kann sich
noch irgendjemand dran erinnern, an den Stream, wo ich meine Tür-Gegensprechanlage versucht
habe den Sound abzugreifen, war da zufällig irgendjemand dabei und kann sich da noch dran
erinnern, ich habe mal einen Stream gemacht vor 2 Jahren oder so, ist schon ewig her,
da habe ich mir eine Tür-Gegensprechanlage gekauft und habe versucht von dort den Sound
abzugreifen und das hat auch funktioniert, ich weiß nicht mehr, welche Library ich verwendet
habe, um den Sound abzuspielen am Ende, wir könnten jetzt ins Archiv gucken, aber ich
habe keine Ahnung mehr, wann das, komm wir gucken jetzt einfach mal wo, Archiv, vielleicht
finden wir es ja im Archiv, Archiv, Search, gucken wir mal, vielleicht, dabei er aber
zu 2 hat, ja, hallo, Search, please, dann ladet es halt runter, ist auch ok, so, haben wir
da irgendwie, wie habe ich, wie könnte ich denn das genannt haben, Tür, Tür, Sound,
Alter, warum mache ich denn das mit Notepad, das geht mir jetzt schon auf den Kicks, damit
ich was Gescheites öffne, wo ist mein, irgendwas meint es mit Sprechanlage, ja, Sprech, Sprech,
ah, smarte Klingel, Tür, Gegensprechanlage, ne, das sind Clips, ne, hier, N-Audio, N-Audio,
ok, ich bin ja, ok, a big brain time, ich habe sogar ein Titel geschrieben, mit was
ich das mache, sehr gut, N-Audio, alles klar, nice, äh, wusstest du, dass der Mars Rover
Passeverance, FFmpeg benutzt, ne, wusste ich nicht, aber auf der anderen Seite wundert
mich das auch nicht, weil FFmpeg, eigentlich das Tool der Wahl ist, wenn du irgendwelches
Video, N und Decoding machen willst, also gerade Open Source, N und Decoding machen
willst, möglichst kompatibel auch zu allem was es gibt, ok, N-Audio heißt das, ok, also,
N-Audio, gut, so, das probieren wir jetzt, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, ich hab keine
Ahnung, NASA benutzt Teamworks, das habe ich in einem Livestream gesehen, ja, mich wundert
das nicht, die brauchen ja eben auch Betriebssysteme, die ordentlich funktionieren, die werden,
die werden ihren Kram bestimmt nicht unter Windows laufen lassen, wusstet ihr, dass die
Panels von SpaceX Elektronen Anwendungen sind, JavaScript, Browser, aber die haben für alles
noch Knöpfe, die Touch-Panels, die Touch-Panels sind einfach nur für die Optik, das wusste
ich gar nicht, dass die mittlerweile Linux verwenden, ich hätte gedacht, die hätten
da irgendwelche Low-Level-lichsten Real-Time-Dinger drauf, JavaScript im Weltall, ja, so weit
sind wir gekommen im Jahr 2021, Raketen fliegen mit JavaScript, kann man sich kaum vorstellen,
ne, ah gut, die Raketen fliegen nicht mit JavaScript, wobei es gar nicht schlecht wäre,
wenn die Raketen mit JavaScript fliegen würden, das wäre wahrscheinlich billiger, stellt
ihr mal vor, stellt euch mal vor, ihr sitzt in der Rakete, das Ding startet und ihr wollt
auf den Touch, auf den Touchscreen drücken und ihr kommt einfach nicht auf den richtigen
Knopf, das ist glaube ich keine so gute Idee, das ist einfach nur Show, die haben für alles
noch Knöpfe, wo es drauf ankommt, 100, 1000%ig, ja, das, also ich habe es noch nicht gesehen,
das Cockpit, aber haben die 100%ig, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe mal in einem
Auto gesessen, weiß gar nicht, was es war, es war kein Tesla, es war, es könnte ja etwas
französisches gewesen sein, was für ein französischer Autohersteller ist bei Elektroautos
gut dabei, Renault, ja, kann sein, aber das war ein bisschen größeres Auto, also es war
nicht so ein Mini, so ein Mini-Teil und die hatten ein Touchscreen, ich fand das total
unintuitiv, da Dinge mit dem Touchscreen zu machen, das habe ich schon halt ausprobiert,
aber ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, ein Auto mit dem Touch zu bedienen, Schweizer
Money, Easy Life, ja, ja, das muss schon super responsive 60 FPS sein, sonst kriege ich
Anfälle, so, also, wir probieren das jetzt mal aus, also wir lesen jetzt mal ein Video
Datei, Video Datei liegt hier, Azubi 2.2, bester Name, Azubi 2.2, aber wie ist denn der richtige
Fahrt dazu, C, Doppelpunkt, Users, Users, Stream, Desktop, Windows-Stells, Azubi 2.2, gut hier, perfekt, Peil, jawoll, zack, zack, so, so, ich habe noch nie Audio decoded mit FFmpeg, ich würde jetzt einfach
mal raten, dass das genauso funktioniert wie Video decoden, ohne es, ohne es je gemacht
zu haben, ich würde, ich probiere das jetzt einfach mal aus, so, wir sehen ja relativ
schnell, ob es funktioniert, wenn es crasht, dann funktioniert es nicht, so, also, den ganzen
Cramp hier können wir uns kopieren, achso, vielleicht sollten wir dieses Library, die
Library erst noch einbinden, Nugget, so, kopieren wir den Kram mal rein, achso, andere
Unsafe muss ich einschalten, ja, ist gut, mache ich, Unsafe, Unsafe, perfekt, so, dass
es ein bisschen ordentlicher ist, sagen wir, irgendwas, dass ich das nicht in Main schreiben
muss, ganz, Moment, das ist ja komplett falsch rum, Alter, so, gut, so, und jetzt gucken
wir mal, ob das, ob das funktioniert, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob ich irgendwie in der Lage,
sag mal, ich will das groß schreiben und das auch, so, und jetzt mal gucken, ob das funktioniert,
so, wir lesen das File ein, ok, also, das können wir da, oh, das ist hier erstmal nicht
relevant, also, wir nehmen das File, mein letztes Video, wir öffnen das File, wir suchen
uns den ersten Stream aus, der wahrscheinlich ein Videostream ist, das funktioniert, jetzt
seht ihr, das ist an der Stelle schon mal kaputt, wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, was
für Audio-Streams überhaupt in der, in der Videodatei, also in dem Video drin sind, so,
also, machen wir mal, gucken wir mal, was, gucken wir mal, was für, was für Streams
in dieser Videodatei drin sind, also, Format, Kontext, Streams, heißt das glaube ich hier,
Streams, und dann, so, zack, cw, Stream, und dann brauche ich irgendwie Name, Codec oder
sowas, Codec und dann Name oder ID oder irgendwas, Codec, ID, dass ich weiß, was da drinne steckt,
so, also ich vermute mal, dass in diesem Video zwei Sachen drin stecken, einen Videostream
und einen Audio-Stream, weil ich meine, das ist, ich habe es ja selbst gerendert, also
ich müsste ja eigentlich wissen, was das Sache ist, so, schauen wir mal, was kommt
da raus, da kommt raus, dass NordExist, ok, ist gut, ist gut, weiß ja, so, also wir haben
einen Stream H264 drinne, genau, das ist das Video und wir haben AAC, das heißt wir brauchen
Stream Nummer 2 bzw. 1 als Index, was macht diese Syntax, wo, wo, sag mal Zeile, was
meinste, 34, ach das da, das ist C++, Pointer-Syntax, das ist ein Pointer, das ist zwar C-Sharp
und nicht C++, aber die haben den gleichen Pfeil für Pointer, das ist quasi der, oh,
wie heißt das offiziell, D-Referencing-Operator oder so, ok, Moment, Moment, Moment, C++
Error-Operator, das heißt wirklich Error-Operator, kann doch nicht sein, Error-Operator, warum
heißt das, der soll, der soll nicht Error-Operator heißen, das soll heißen wie das, was es macht,
ok, C-Sharp, nicht den, nicht den, nicht den, unsave, egal, zumindest ist das D-Referencing,
also der nimmt den Pointer, macht den Pointer zu einem, guckt was das für, also, Pointer
ist ja nichts anderes, wie, das ist auch was, das kann ich vielleicht an der Stelle noch
mal kurz erzählen, ich hab mir früher, also früher, als ich angefangen hab mit so Programmier-Stellts,
ich hab mir immer unglaublich schwer getan, gerade in C, was die sich unter einem Pointer
vorstellen und meistens wird dann in Tutorials gesagt, Pointer, Pointer ist quasi eine Adresse
im Arbeitsspeicher, das stimmt, aber, das stimmt schon, aber das ist nicht, das ist nur die
halbe Wahrheit, denn Pointer ist in eigentlich zwei Sachen, das ist einmal eine Adresse im
Speicher und die Typinformation, was es ist, die zwei Sachen brauchst du, weil eine Speicheradresse
alleine bringt dir nichts, wenn du eine Speicheradresse alleine hast, dann hast du ja keine Ahnung,
als was du die Daten, die da stehen, an der Speicheradresse interpretieren musst, du brauchst
den Typ und du brauchst die Speicheradresse und wenn du die Speicheradresse und den Typ
hast, dann weißt du, was du mit den Daten anfangen kannst, also ein Pointer ist die
Kombination von Typ und Speicheradresse, so merke ich mir das immer, so, also, nenn die
Klasse mal FFM keck, du meinst, du meinst hier die Funktion, FFM keck, nice, in C ist
der Typ nicht dabei, ja, also, das, ja ja, ich glaube, bei den meisten Sprachen geht
das im Binary letztendlich verloren, was es ist, weil du hast ja, du hast ja dann auch
Hardcoded drinne stehen, so nach dem Motto, gucke an byte Position 2, da gucke an byte
Position 5, was auch immer, da musst du dich halt drauf verlassen können, dass das drin
steht,.NET ist das IL drinne, am Ende wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr.
Warum private static unsafe, ne, weil das hier Speicheradressen, direkter Zugriff auf
Speicheradressen ist und das hier nen Pointer auf irgendwelche Native Sachen, da muss der
unsafe machen, sobald ich unsafe rausnehme, dann sagt er Bam, geht nicht, weil es C Interop
gedürnt ist, also ok, jetzt sollen wir anfangen, ich brauche Stream Nummer 1, guck, Stream
oder beziehungsweise Stream, Stream Index 1, der erste Stream ist Video Stream, der zweite
Stream ist Audio, also, guck mal mal, also, nehmen wir mal, wir nehmen mal Hardcoded Stream
1, so, guck mal, ob ich das richtige hab, Stream, Codec, Aldi und AAC soll das jetzt
sein, jawoll.
Ok, jetzt suchen wir uns mal ein Beispiel raus, FFmpeg Examples, ähm, Audio, Audio Decode,
wir haben nämlich ein ganz gutes Beispiel dafür, die Code Audio, 2001 tolles, ja genau,
ne, doch, das meine ich, so, Big Brain Beispiel, äh, das ist jetzt zwar ein C, das ist aber
nicht so schlimm, man kann, das ist, das ist, das ist ziemlich, ziemlich nahe, nah am originalen
gerappt hier, der C Sharp Wrapper, Wrapper für FFmpeg, da kann man sich das eigentlich
ganz gut abgucken, also, was muss ich jetzt machen, um Audio zu decoden, lass mal kurz,
Monka essen hier, AV Codec Send Package, das mach ich hier, AV Codec Send Package,
ah, das hab ich noch gar nicht kopiert, ah, Sekunde, Sekunde, äh, ich kopier, ich kopier
den anderen Gampel auch nochmal mit, so, ok, also wenn das jetzt klappt, glaub ich nicht,
dass das funktioniert, so, den ganzen Kram können wir rausschmeißen, alles weg, While,
True, jawoll, und wenn der Teil fertig gelesen ist, einfach Break und gut ist, so, also, AV
Read Frame, AV, AV Read, wo haben die das, Read Frame, so, jetzt muss ich mich hier um
irgendwelche, ok, wie machen die das hier, ich teste jetzt einfach, ob das so funktioniert,
wie ich mir das vorstelle, wahrscheinlich nicht, also Videos decoded man so, das ist
relativ easy, mit FFmpeg, ich sag, lese einen neuen Frame ein, äh, Frame ein, das ist ein
Frame, in FFmpeg ist quasi die Menge an Daten, die man braucht, um ein ganzes Bild zu bekommen,
dann schicke ich das in den Decoder und, äh, lese es aus dem Decoder wieder auf und aus
und ich hab RGB im RAM, also das Bild in RGB oder BGR oder was auch immer, aber halt decoded,
so, mal gucken, ob das mit Audio auch funktioniert, ich führ das jetzt einfach mal aus und gucke,
ob's funktioniert, Moment, blub, ok, der decoded, ich weiß nicht, ob er decoded, er macht, er
macht Dinger, ähm, gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert, packet, äh, Duration oder so, ok, der liest
Sachen ein, also, das Einlesen von der Datei funktioniert wie bei Videos, so, der Codec
stimmt doch auch, ne, hatte ich eben geguckt, Moment, ich muss gucken, ob das Codec, ob
das Codec starten funktioniert, das muss ich nochmal schnell checken, weil wenn das Codec
starten, äh, fürs Decoding nicht funktioniert, dann kann ich's gleich vergessen, hat funktioniert,
ok, ich würd fast sagen, dass das funktioniert, send package, receive, ok, frame, so, ok, ich
würd sagen, es funktioniert doch nicht, äh, also, das als, das als Timestamp kann's ja
nicht sein, das als Timestamp ergibt keinen Sinn, es ist keine C++ Library, das ist eine
C Library FFmpeg, C Libraries ist das beste, was es gibt, erstens, weil C eine gescheite
Programmiersprache ist und zweitens, weil Interop mit C in jeder x-bliebenen Programmiersprache
funktioniert, im Gegensatz zu C++, C++ ist eine kack Programmiersprache und Interop mit
C++ ist schwierig, also C all the way, da gibt mir der Patrick sicherlich recht, was
machen die Fall, das ist Pointer, Pointer, wie in C, wieso soll das bei C++ schwieriger
sein, weil die intern ganz viele, äh, Umbenennungen von Funktionen und Geduldens machen, also
du kannst nicht einfach sagen in C++, also du kannst nicht einfach eine C++ Library nehmen
und dann sagen, hier rufe Funktion mit Namen abc auf, die, die, die Mängel C++ vorher
um und die heißt dann anders, du musst dann explizit sagen, wenn du das in C++ machen
willst, musst du explizit sagen, ja, ich deklariere das nochmal neu und schreibe explizit dabei,
es soll als C ähm, als, als, als C Aufruf exportiert werden, genau, die Zahl eben ist
long min, ja, das heißt schonmal, das ist, das kann nicht sein, wenn das der Timestamp
ist, das ergibt keinen Sinn, der Timestamp, der Timestamp, ähm, passt, passt so nicht,
ich muss mal, ich, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet, Overlaychamp kann ich wegmachen, genau, so
siehts aus, das ist halt das Problem, hast du halt in C nicht, ne, das hast du in Rust,
in Rust kannst du es übrigens auch ganz gut machen, Rust kannst du auch ganz gut, ähm,
markieren als, mach mal C, C export, also C ist das, die einfachste Sprache für Interop,
alles, was in C programmiert ist, kannst du easier verwenden, im Gegensatz zu C++, Chandler
hat wieder irgendwas gequalmt vorm Stream, ich sehs schon, halt wieder, ja, ich, ich,
ich, ich weiß gar nicht, was ist eigentlich, warum diese Belohnung überhaupt jemals jemand
einlöst, warum lässt man sich freiwillig, freiwillig timeouten, das, genau, das kommt
noch dazu, dass C++ an sich noch nicht mal kompatibel zu C++ selbst ist, das ist eh,
die sind komplett, komplett lost, die C++ Leute, gut, Leute, das funktioniert nicht,
weiß ich hier mache, also wir gucken uns mal den, den Returnwert an, von, von, von dem,
von dem Decode, Decoding, ob das, ob das funktioniert, und ja, ich könnte dann nen Breakpoint setzen,
aber, who cares, wer braucht Breakpoints, so, wollen wir hier gleich, hören wir gleich
danach auf, schauen wir mal, ob das wenigstens, das sieht nicht gut aus, Returncode minus
5 und 8 Trillionen und minus 11, das sieht so aus, als funktioniert das so nicht, das
geht nicht, gut, ok, Beispiel, Beispiel, Beispielcode angucken, also was machen die hier, Decode,
Code, Kontext, Packet und Frame, gut, das, soweit bin ich auch, und was machen die hier
in Main, ah, ok, das ist schwierig zu lesen, was machen die hier, Finddecoder, das mache
ich auch alles, AVParser init, das brauche ich nicht, das habe ich alles schon, Codec
Open habe ich auch schon gemacht, das funktioniert, was zum, was ist AVParser Pass 2, was haben
die sich denn da wieder ausgedacht, was ist AVParser Pass 2, das ist wieder genial benannt,
es ist nicht AVParser Pass 1, es ist, nein, es ist AVParser Pass 2, ok, was macht es,
Pass a Packet, aber ich will kein, oi, ich habe keine Ahnung, was die damit machen, und
was machen die, das check ich nicht, was, was machen die denn da, ok, hier lesen sie
das ganze ein, Moment, das ist doch das gleiche, was ich hier mache, oder, AVReadFrame, ist
AVReadFrame vielleicht nur für Videos und nicht für Audio, und jetzt sagt nicht, ja,
frame ist ganz klar Video, das ist in FFmpeg nicht so klar, he doesn't know, als würde
der Chat knowen, Leute, als würde der Chat knowen, ihr knowt genauso wenig, ihr knowt
auch nichts, don't tell him, ihr habt auch keine Ahnung, AVReadFrame, ok, Audio, FFmpeg,
ich muss da suchen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert, this tutorial, ok, Poggers,
Tutorial, ist das Cobol, ach ne, der denkt, es ist einfacher als so, ok, ok, verstehe,
ja, OpenInput, FindStreamInfo, habe ich alles schon gemacht, AVDumpFormat, das können wir
tatsächlich machen, dass wir mal ausgeben lassen, das machen wir jetzt tatsächlich,
FFmpeg, AVDumpFormat, und jetzt, was, Index, IndexStream1, will, will, be, what, ok, ok,
wenn die, wenn der Output mich schon überfordert, was möchtest du mit FFmpeg, ich will einfach
nur Audio auslesen und dann Audio abspielen, Video weiß ich, wie das funktioniert, aber
Audio habe ich noch nie gemacht, einfach nur den Text, ok, Text, CACW, das wird nicht
funktionieren, und jetzt, was, ist Output, das ist ein Input, ok, ok, hier, hier, da
steht es doch, Input, CACW, das ist H264, ach Moment, ich brauche ja auch Index0, habe
ich doch gesagt, ach guck mal, hier ist doch, AudioARC, gut, dass das funktioniert, also,
das ist alles richtig aufgeworfen, wenn ich jetzt nur wüsste, wie das, wie ist man den
Scheiß aus, kann das sein, dass das nicht funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle?
CodecType, AV Media Typ Video, ok, ok, ok, ok, das gucken wir jetzt mal, was, was, was,
der müsste ja bei mir hier Type Audio sagen, Stream, was, was macht der hier, CodecType
gibt es überhaupt nicht, ach nee, darf man nicht mehr, darf man nicht mehr, ist Deprecated,
aber wen interessiert das, ok, Audio, das ist prinzipiell, prinzipiell richtig, was
ich hier mache, das hat gar kein Audio, oder, Audio, kacke, wtf, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
fuck, Video Stream is obtained until Video Stream is found, ja, gut, Video Stream juckt
mich ja auch nicht, Type Video, nee, Moment, der macht ganz was anderes, das will ich überhaupt
nicht machen, was, was der da macht, ok, ok, ich muss, ich muss mir das Example, das
Example angucken, also, big, big brain time, jetzt haben wir, finde ich, ist übel schwer
zu lesen, Achtung Flashbang Warning, ist auch nicht besser, ich lasse lieber so, also was
machen die denn jetzt hier, if, ich muss das so machen, das geht nicht anders, ich glaube
ich kann nicht einfach sagen Read Frame für Audio, ich glaube das funktioniert nicht
so, ok, Stack Overflow, FFmpeg, Read Audio, AAC, keine Ahnung irgendwas, AV Packet, Stack
Overflow rette uns, please, encode, perfekt, jawoll, zeig her, encode, nein, decode, decode,
hier, bam, decode, das mache ich, ja, Package, blablabla, das brauchen wir doch alles gar
nicht, ah, ah, decode audio 4, alles klar, nicht nur pass 2 decode audio 4, AV Read Frame,
genau das mache ich doch, ah hier, hier ist Example, Print Audio Frame Info, ok, big brain
time, channels, ah, AV Sample FMT ist Planer, was, ok, also, ja, so schlau bin ich auch
schon, Open Input, alles klar, habe ich, Codec, habe ich auch, ja, ja, bis hier hin komme
ich ja, das habe ich ja alles, channels, wie viele channels habe ich, das muss ich nachgucken,
Codec Index Channels, wie viele, wie viele Audio Channels habe ich, das muss ich wahrscheinlich
dann pro Channel machen oder sowas, Channels, wahrscheinlich 2, 0, 0, wie kann ich 0 Audio
Channels haben, hä, aber 0 Audio Channels ergeben doch gar keinen Sinn, in dem das Video
kein Audio, klar hat es Audio, ich kann sogar abspielen, hallo Leute hier ist der Max und
für viele angehende Fachinformatiker Azubis, oder generell für viele angehende neue Azubis,
natürlich hat es Audio, Channels 0, Moment habe ich irgendwie vergessen sowas wie, aber
ne ich sag, Codec Open, das ist genau das was ich machen muss und das ist auch erfolgreich,
Codec Open funktioniert auch, ich bin jetzt echt überfragt was der für Schmerzen hat,
Codec Open funktioniert, was programmiere ich, ich will einfach, einfach Audio auslesen
aus einer Videodatei, Sven Supreme, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub, Rex, ein linkes Ei, alles
klar, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub, gut live 0, huge Prime Subscription, danke dir
Leute, Leute hier, huge, huge, big brain Leute mit am Start, ok ich hab kein, ich hab, ich
hab legit kein Plastenschimmer, also wenn das so nicht funktioniert, also warum, warum,
ok Sample Rate, Sample Rate sollte doch dann aber wenigstens drin sein, Sample, Sample
Rate, Sample Rate ist 0, Moment, Moment, da kann doch irgendwas nicht stimmen, da kann
doch irgendwas nicht stimmen, ah vielleicht muss ich Read Stream Info, wobei ich hab Read
Stream Info gemacht, ok das ist, das ist, das ist das Problem, also 0 Channels, 0 Sample
Rate ergibt da überhaupt keinen Sinn, was denn das bei, das ist der, das ist der Stream,
das ist der Audio Stream, das ist der Audio Stream, AAC Audio Stream, und ich sag Open,
Codec Open, das sagt auch, dass es erfolgreich ist, ich mach das hier mal raus, dass es nicht
weiter verwirrt, aber versteh ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, was hat er für Schmerzen, warum
ist die Sample Rate, muss ich das irgendwie erst noch, aber normalerweise ist es danach,
danach funktionsfähig, ok hab ich irgendwas übersehen, Best Streams, warum hat das keine
Channels, da ist die richtige Datei, er sagt hier auch, das ist eine AAC Audio Spur hat
da gefunden, das ist alles richtig, nur dass, nur dass die aus irgendwelchen Gründen, keine
Channels hat, jetzt kein Wunder, dass es nicht funktioniert, es hat keine Channels, aber,
es ist ein Audio, aber es ist, es ist ein Audio Stream, ok jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab
ich kein Plan mehr, wo das Problem ist, Streams Audio Stream, AV Codec Open 2, genau das
mach ich und das hat keinen Fehler, die backt doch mal, was soll ich denn debacken, Seite
35, ne eigentlich nicht, wie macht der das hier, Code Context, ach guck mal, der nehmt
den, hä das geht, Moment, ich würd sogar eher sagen, das ist falsch was der hier macht,
ich würd sogar sagen, das ist falsch, der nehmt nämlich was Deprecated Funktion, ich
mein ich kann das mal machen, aber eigentlich, er sagt ja sogar schon hier, dass es Deprecated
ist, das soll man nicht mal verwenden, Moment, jetzt geht das, ok jetzt hab ich irgendwas
Deprecated, das benutzt auch ok, was ist der FFmpeg, ist so eigentlich das Ding schlechthin
was man dafür verwendet, ok es ist mir egal, dass es Deprecated ist, es funktioniert, dann
lass ich das so, wenn es jetzt funktioniert, ich hab keine Schwierigkeiten, juckt mich
dann ob es Deprecated ist oder nicht, so decode der jetzt wenigstens auch richtig, was, was
soll mir das überhaupt sagen, eine Güte, es ist aber mal gut ja, ne, Number of Bands
31 Exceeds Limit 5, ahja, alles klar, Obvious Leute, Obvious, komplett klar, das ist total
outdated Code, das macht man überhaupt nicht mehr so, wait a minute, warte, ne, ne das ist
es nicht, das ist es, wobei doch, warte, Moment, ich weiß woran das liegt, passt mal auf,
Lull, Package Type, der liest sowohl Video als auch Audio ein, kann das sein, der liest
Video und Audio ein, ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken, ist das überhaupt Audio, Stream Index,
wartet mal, daran wird das liegen, guckt mal, der liest beides ein, Moment, Moment, ja der
liest Audio und Video ein, ja kein Wunder, dass ich Video nicht als Audio decoden kann,
das ist eigentlich logisch, ne, Chat, und das habt ihr angeblich schon gewusst, das war
von Anfang an klar, oder, ja, natürlich, also, if Stream Index ungleich 1, ja, continue,
alles klar, gut, gut, gut, gut, jetzt, jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich, ne, Moment, das muss
ich auch lassen, wir hatten ja 2 Fehler, das waren ja 2 Fehler, einmal das und das andere,
schon vom Speedport Pro Plus, von was für einem Ding, haben die mal wieder eine Fritzbox
geforkt oder was, Moment, ich guck mal kurz rein, was für ein Ding, bitte was, könnt
ihr bitte Gaming wählen, Moment, was, was hat die Telekom, Sekunde, das muss ich jetzt
angucken, mit hoher Geschwindigkeit zum optimalen Gaming Erlebnis, die Telekom lauscht eine
limitierte Gaming Edition des Speedport Pro Plus mit Gaming, jetzt fangen die auch schon
mit so einem Schwachsinn an und Ambient Light, doch 22 Likes, doch so viel, also, ganz ehrlich,
das ist so hektisch gefilmt, du erkennst ja gar nichts, Alter, wer hat das geschnitten,
da wird es ja mehr schlecht bei, ich erkenne nichts, ich erkenne nichts, was zum, ist es
das, ist es das, oder wie, ich erkenne nichts, WTF, Alter, jetzt, ich kann nicht mal, ich
kann auch nicht mal Pause drücken, das ist, ja, ist klar, Boomer Reflexe, natürlich, okay,
Speedport Gaming Edition, ist das heute der 1.
April, irgendwie, nee, ne, so schaut es, naja, naja,
schnell und stabil dank Gaming WLAN, das bedeutet, ihr normales WLAN ist nicht schnell und stabil,
entwickelt mit professionellen Gamern, SK Gaming, ja, die machen alles für Geld, wenn die Telekom
zu mir sagt und sagen, Max, wir geben dir 2000 Euro Promote mal den Speedport, dann
möchtest du das wahrscheinlich auch machen und die kriegen mehr dafür, was ich nicht
verstehe ist, warum muss SK Gaming über WLAN spielen, die haben das überhaupt nicht, ergibt
überhaupt keinen Sinn, 400 Euro, boah, boah, das ist ordentlich, was haben die, was machen
die denn da rein, haben die, ja, keine Ahnung, verplatiente Antennen oder, wobei Gold ist
ja mittlerweile teurer als Platin, also vergoldete Antennen, was können die denn, der Schnitt
ist der Wahnsinn, also wer das geschnitten hat, der möchte krampfhaft hier Hipper Gamer
Hacker Man sein, okay, das ist Schwachsinn, das ist doch irgendein Telekom Fanboy, oder,
Telekom Fangirl, also ich meine, wenn du schon eine Magenta Maske auf hast und so ein Avatar
in Magenta, dann bist du, Telekom Botschafter, ah, der erste externe Telekom Botschafter,
na, dass er das geil findet, ist, dass sie das geil findet, ist ja klar, nur noch warten,
bis ich WLAN habe, dann leg ich mir das Teil, hä, also du bist ja immer dümmer beim Kommentare
lesen, wie bis ich WLAN habe, das Ding ist dafür da, dass du WLAN bekommst, oder verstehe
ich die Genialität nicht, ah, bis ein Anschluss kommt, okay, das ist, ich denke immer nicht
an die 3 Head Noobs, auch ins 5 Genes, das ist ja komplett, komplett schwachsinnig, vor
allem, mich würde ja mal interessieren, was genau, Moment, was sagt YouTube dazu, das
gibt es auch bestimmt schon auf YouTube, in zweifels war halt Semper Video schon was hochgeladen,
hallo in diesem Video nur ganz kurz der neue Telekom Gaming Router mal näher betrachtet,
Schadwehr ist da bestimmt mehr drauf, Schadwehr, ähm, was, Gaming via WLAN, guck mal mein
Video ist vorne, perfekt, Teppo weiter, genau, aber so spreche ich das auch aus, hab mich
da gar nicht Lust bekommen, okay, das gibt es da, ah ne Moment, das ist doch hier, Gaming
WLAN Ping wie im E-Sport, Ping wie im E-Sport, als ist, als hat der Ping was mit E-Sport
oder nicht zu tun, okay, das Leute, wir müssen kurz unterbrechen, das muss ich mir jetzt
angucken, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, das ist viel zu laut.
Und natürlich Julia und Lisa, unseren beiden Telekom Tech-House, die euch das Gerät vorstellen.
Telekom Grills am Start.
Ja hallo, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge.
Habe ich dann auch einen besseren Ping in das Rechenzentrum nach Indien, was ich brauche
für YouTube Premium für vier Euro im Monat, äh, für drei Monate?
Unka, wir beide sind auch heute gar nicht alleine da, sondern wir haben unseren lieben
Kollegen Manuel eingeladen, der ist nämlich begeisterter Gamer und der kann uns den Router
viel besser bewerten, als wir es eigentlich können.
Okay, also ich hab da überhaupt keine Ahnung von, alles klar, da ist er, okay, dem kauf
ich das auch direkt ab, der hat Ahnung, mit dem kann ich mich identifizieren.
Boah, what's your favorite color, Magenta, das Ding sieht nicht schön aus, ich dachte
am Anfang auch noch, das kommt auf den Bildern schlecht raus, aber das sieht, äh, das sieht
aus wie eine alte Kontrollleuchte, sowieso wie so alte Kontrollleuchten, also nicht, nicht...
Ich bin Manuel und wie ihr schon gesagt habt, arbeite ich natürlich auch für die Deutsche
Telekom, aber heute bin ich in meiner Lieblingsrolle da, nämlich als Gamer und nicht nur, dass
ich das privat mache und auch schon seitdem ich glaube ich fünf bin, sondern seit kurzem
habe ich auch einen YouTube-Kanal und möchte auch bald mit Twitchstream loslegen, bin damit
das klassische Gamer-Klischee, den würde ich gerne mal interviewen, was manche Telekom-Sachen
angehen, der scheint ja Ahnung zu haben und macht netten Eindruck, haben die, haben die
sein Channel verlinkt?
Oh, geht steil, den würde ich gerne mal zu ein paar, wobei, das hat keinen Sinn, das
hat keinen Sinn, wenn er bei der Telekom arbeitet, kann er ja nichts sagen, heute hier zu sein,
aber bevor ich jetzt zu viel verrate, vielleicht verratet ihr uns mal, worum es denn heute
genau geht.
Ja, es geht um die limitierte Gaming-Edition des Speedport Pro Plus, das ist die Gaming-Variante
unseres...
Was würdest du ihn fragen?
Na zum Beispiel, was Gaming-Ping ist.
Was ist Gaming-Ping?
Vielleicht kann er mir das ja sinnvoll erklärt.
... von der Telekom.
Wir zeigen euch den Router, geben euch die wichtigsten Facts, natürlich zusammen mit
unserem Gaming-Enthusiasten Manuel und haben gleich im Interview auch noch Martin von SK
Gaming, die nutzen den Router nämlich in ihrem Teamhaus selbst und können uns also
sagen, wie er sich dort schlägt, aber jetzt erstmal die three things...
Und die verwenden den über WLAN?
Die SK Gaming spielen Erden, das glaube ich nicht, das haben die nur zur Show gemacht.
Warum sollten die um alles in der Welt über WLAN spielen?
Das Gaming-Edition-Router ist ausgestattet mit den neuesten Standards wie WIFI 6.
Übrigens, absolut Hi-Res Schrift hier an der Stelle, die Schrift ist, klar, die Schrift
ist pixelig.
Also, ist ausgestattet mit den neuesten Standards WIFI 6, mit 12 WLAN, okay, viel hilft viel
für alle Leute mit 20 Geräten gleichzeitig, die volle Pulle senden und empfangen wollen.
Mesh-Unterschützung, Smart Home-Kompatibilität, gut, WIFI 6 kannst du nicht nichts gegen beschweren,
mehr Antennen sind auch nicht verkehrt, Mesh-Unterschützung ist aktuell auch nicht, also da kann ich
nichts gegen sagen, ob es halt 400 Euro kosten muss, dann doch lieber drei, vier ordentliche
Access-Points im Haus verteilt und die angeschlossen an irgendwas gescheites Zentrales.
Okay, das lasse ich jetzt einfach mal unkommentiert, ich meine, wenn der Router Ambilight braucht,
dann, ja, gut, was auch immer, ich wüsste nicht mal, wo man sich den Router angucken
würde normalerweise, wo das irgendwie Sinn machen würde, dass der Ambilight hat, kann
man das auch steuern?
Haben die irgendeine Router-RGB-App, oder wie, oder, ja, das will ich mir 400 Euro auch
hoffen.
Tatsächlich ist das mal ein Gadget aus unserer eigenen Garage, wir haben die Power des besten
Routers an die Bedürfnisse der Gamer angepasst und mit ein paar zusätzlichen Features ausgestattet,
aber jetzt mal an Manuel, schläg dein Gamer-Herz höher, wenn du diesen Router siehst.
Ehrliche Antwort, oh, nee, das Ding sieht nicht, das sieht aus wie eine Kaffeemaschine,
guck dir mal, das sieht aus wie eine Kaffeemaschine mit Kontrollleuchten, hier unten kommt die
Tasse drauf und hier oben kommt der Kaffee raus.
Also, okay, hübsch ist es nicht, hübsch ist das Teil echt nett.
Was ist das für eine Frage, fuck, ich muss jetzt so klingen, als antworte ich da irgendwie
ehrlich drauf und, ja, ich muss jetzt irgendwie überzeugend klingen.
Natürlich, natürlich, ja.
Boah, ist das hässlich, Alter, ist dieses Ding hässlich.
Fuck, das sieht aus wie eine Retro, irgendwie so eine Retro, ich kann es gar nicht beschreiben,
irgendwie so eine Retrokiste, die versucht, Retro auszusehen, wie man sich 1980 die Zukunft
vorgestellt hat.
Wisst ihr, so wie man früher die Zukunft dargestellt hat, mit vielen Statusleuchten
und sowas.
So sieht das Ding aus, also, ich glaube nicht, dass es Absicht ist, generell, wenn sich
die LEDs selber im Gehäuse spiegeln, sieht das meistens immer nicht gut aus, egal, machen
wir mal weiter.
Das sieht aus, als hätte in den 80ern einer versucht einen Akustikkoppler zu pimpen, ja,
so ein bisschen.
Wann haben sie das hochgeladen, warte mal, wann haben die das gepostet?
Heute um 13, da sind so Leute, hätt ich heute ein Video zu machen können, hätt ich das
mal früher gesehen, muss ich morgen machen, okay, das Ding sieht so kacke aus.
Guckt euch das mal an, das sieht so krass gewollt und nicht gekonnt aus, es ist unglaublich.
Das sieht wirklich aus, wir wollten es cool machen, konnten es aber nicht.
Vor allem, du kriegst ja epileptische Anteam, müssen wir ja Epilepsiewarnung senden eigentlich
hier davor.
Das ist die, die unsere Kunden wirklich brauchen, wahrscheinlich auch viel mehr als unsere Kunden
im Durchschnitt brauchen und das ist daher der beste seiner Gattung und das ist jetzt
einfach nur die Gaming Edition, also neben dem, dass der Router wirklich großartig ist,
sieht er auch noch geil aus.
Nein, nein, nein.
Also, mal unabhängig von den technischen Qualitäten, aber geil sieht er nicht aus.
Ja, das Design ist schon mal richtig futuristisch.
Das sieht aus, wisst ihr wie das aussieht, wie ein Spielautomat.
Das sieht aus, vielleicht ist das sogar die Absicht, vielleicht soll das aussehen wie
ein Spielautomat ein bisschen.
Also, wenn man sich das dabei gedacht hätte, dann hätte das sogar noch irgendwie, dann
würde ich das Design ja noch verstehen, aber es sieht trotzdem kacke aus.
Warum ist das Ding so groß, nein, die 12 Antennen müssen ja irgendwo rein.
Im halb durchsichtigen Gehäuse und natürlich hat der Router auch Ambient Light, da braucht
man den gar nicht mehr zu verstecken, sondern kann den quasi als Deko-Element ins Wohnzimmer
stellen.
Die zwei Mädels, die zwei Mädels würde ich jetzt gerne fragen, ob die sich im Wohnzimmer
dieses Ding auf den Wohnzimmertisch stellen würden.
Frauen sind bei sowas immer besonders skeptisch, das würde ich die gerne jetzt fragen, so
nach dem Motto, würdet ihr euch das daheim auf den Wohnzimmertisch stellen?
Ich glaube nicht, also außerdem stell dir mal vor, du hast so ein Wohnzimmertisch stehen,
guckst da noch Fernseh und das lenkt dich ja permanent im Augenwinkel ab.
Die Gaming-Konsole, tatsächlich hat die Beleuchtung noch einen anderen Zweck, wenn etwas nicht
stimmt und man da so eingreifen muss, dann macht er sich bemerkbar und leuchtet anders.
Na, dann blinkt die Bude wie ein Klopp.
Mega.
Wie kann das gute Ding denn?
Ja, was muss man für gewöhnliches als erstes machen?
Einen Router einstapseln und der ganze Prozess ist einrichtend echt super easy.
Stromkabel rein, DSL-Kabel rein, das war's.
Nach 5 Minuten hat er sich eigentlich selbst eingerechnet.
Ja, finde ich super.
Da kann ich in der Zeit einfach schnell in den Kapitän gehen, wenn ich wiederkomme,
machen wir die Klappe auf.
Ui.
Wie?
Ich muss da nichts eingeben?
Der kommt dann schon vorkonfiguriert mit meinen Zugangsdaten drin oder wie?
Ja gut, wenn ich das mit meinem Account bestelle, kann man das machen.
Ob ich das will, sei mal dahingestellt.
Es sieht doch aus wie eine Kaffeemaschine, oder?
Zugangs geht heute automatisch, siehst du mal, wie lange ich schon keinen DSL-Anschluss
mehr hab.
Echt nicht?
Ich hab seit Jahren keinen DSL-Anschluss mehr, keine Ahnung.
Sieht schlecht, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wo man mit Wireshark Benutzerdaten mitschneiden
konnte, weil die Telekom lange Zeit, was war das, Papp oder Chub, was keine Verschlüsselung
hatte, verwendet hat für PPoE-Authentifizierung.
Was, ein paar Sekunden zurück, das billige Plastik, okay.
Moment, was für eine Karte mach ich da rein?
Ah, Kabel.
Ja gut.
Ja, finde ich super.
Da kann ich in der Zeit einfach schnell einen Kabel dringen gehen, wenn ich wiederkomme.
Machen wir mal die Klappe auf.
Ui.
Ja, nehme ich den Zettel da raus.
Ja, die Klappe hört sich wirklich billig an.
Ich muss mich aber morgen zusammenreißen, also wenn ich da ein Video rüber mache, dann
will ich kein Video machen, wo ich von A bis Z da drüber rente.
Ich muss versuchen, mich da wirklich mal normal mit auseinanderzusetzen, so bescheuert das
jetzt klingt, aber.
Da ist ein kleiner QR-Kontrag, den kann man scannen mit seinem Handy.
Zack, das ist im WLAN.
Zack.
Das ist einfach.
Und die User werden auch die anderen Funktionen bekommen.
Zack, Leute.
Der neue Wi-Fi 6 Standard zum Beispiel ermöglicht es, eine viel stabilere und schnellere Verbindung
zu haben.
Der Router funkt nämlich auf unterschiedlichen Kanälen, so kann er auch mit anderen Routern
und Netzwerken kommunizieren.
Und was bringt mir das am Ende des Tages?
Ja, du hast natürlich eine stabilere und schnellere Verbindung und du hast auch eine
höhere Reichweite.
Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel auf dem Balkon oder auf der Terrasse mit deiner Sonne, Box,
Musik machen willst, dann kannst du halt sicher sein, dass da auch die Reichweite da ist.
Und durch die Mesh-Funktionalität, kann der Router auch mit anderen Routern oder Repeatern
zusammengeschlossen werden.
Durch neue Technologien wie zum Beispiel Spatial Reuse und BSS Coloring, kann der Router eine
konstant hohe Bandbreite sein.
Was ist?
Okay.
Jetzt hört es bei mir auch auf.
Was ist BSS Coloring?
Ich hab wirklich keinen...
Was für ein Ding?
BSS Coloring.
Okay, das ist... hab ich keine Ahnung von...
Das ist, wie sich die Channels überschneiden, oder?
Okay, BSS Coloring, man lernt sogar im Telekom Video noch was.
Das ist zum Beispiel praktisch, wenn hier die Kinder im Internet spielen und mein Mann
guckt einen Film und ich bin in der Videokonferenz.
Irgendwas machst du falsch.
Bates-Champ.
Ich frag mich echt, wie die reagieren würde, wenn ihr einen Kerl mit diesem Router daheim
anrückt und den auf den Wohnzimmertisch knallt und sagt, okay, BAM, RGB-Router, den stellen
wir jetzt dahin.
Die will den bestimmt nicht dastehen haben.
Wettig mit euch.
Die will den da nicht stehen haben.
Aber genau dann, in dem Moment, sorgt der Bruder dafür, dass alle ihren Spaß haben
außer mir.
Normalerweise würde das dann ruckeln oder wie man hätte Netzwerkprobleme, aber das
funktioniert dann eben einwandfrei.
Jetzt nochmal zu Manuel.
Manuel, was sagst du denn als Gamer zu Gaming über WLAN?
Er ist mal ausgelacht und jetzt muss er sagen, okay, ich muss ernst sein, ich muss ernst werden.
Gamer und auch jeder Technikexperte würde mich jetzt schallend auslachen, wenn ich jetzt
hier in die Kamera sage, Gaming über WLAN, das ist die Zukunft, aber ich habe es ausprobiert
mit dem Speedpod Pro Gaming Edition.
Es ist gar nicht mehr so abwegig, wie das vielleicht lange Zeit war.
Die Technik hat sich da auch verändert und es liegt vor allen Dingen sicherlich an der
Wi-Fi 6 Technologie.
Es ist nicht viel langsamer als über ein LAN-Kabel und es ist letzten Endes auch nicht
irgendwie störanfälliger, also ich habe den Unterschied nicht wirklich gemerkt.
Aber es gibt nur eins, was besser ist als ein Kabel, das ist ein noch besseres, dickeres,
besser isoliertes Kabel.
Letzten Endes hat dieser Router genialerweise auch noch eine WLAN-Gaming-Funktion, das heißt
also alle Daten, die im Bezug auf Spiele laufen, die über den Spieleport laufen, die werden
tatsächlich priorisiert und dadurch wird die Störanfälligkeit auch reduziert.
Das macht ein bisschen QoS, was aber komplett unsinnig ist, wenn das Ding nicht ausgelastet
ist.
Also so die ganzen QoS-Maßnahmen, die es gibt auch bei anderen Geräten oder was teilweise
als extra, es gab ja mal eine Zeit lang Geräte, die so etwas quasi nichts anderes gemacht
haben als so etwas nur in einem extra Gerät, das Problem haben die allermeisten, also die
meisten Leute haben gar kein Problem, was damit behoben wird, weil du musst Spiele-Daten
und Sachen und VoIP nur priorisieren, wenn so viel los ist auf deinem Router, dass es
Stau gibt, nur dann macht das Sinn.
Also wenn du jetzt, keine Ahnung, 400 MBit hast, oder was ist VDSL, 400 down, 40 up oder
50 up, 500 down oder irgendwie sowas, 250, Chainload, das gucken wir doch gerade, oder?
Ja, also wenn du 250 down, 50 up hast, dann haben die meisten Leute nicht das Problem,
dass das sich in irgendeiner Art und Weise staut.
Ja also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde, ok, ich lade ein YouTube-Video hoch,
guck nebenbei auf dem zweiten Rechner 4K Amazon, drüben auf dem Fernseher läuft noch ein
4K Amazon-Stream und nebenbei machen noch zwei Geräte Updates und ich möchte dabei jetzt
wirklich noch was auch immer, irgendwas competitive, Multiplayer spielen, dann wäre das sinnvoll,
aber das ist ja normalerweise nicht so.
Der macht eine gute Figur darin und die Zukunft rückt, was Gaming über WLAN betrifft, auf
jeden Fall ein Stück näher.
Das geht mit der Telekom, das geht sonst nicht, das geht sonst natürlich nicht, das geht
nur mit der Telekom, das kann auch sonst keiner außer der Telekom, danke Magenta, dass du
uns rettest.
Und noch ein anderes Problem löst der Router, und zwar kennen wir das alle, nämlich, dass
der Akku schneller leer geht, als uns lieb ist und wenn wir das Handy überhaupt nicht
benutzen.
Was?
Was hat der Router mit dem Akku?
Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Was?
Der macht eine gute Figur darin und die Zukunft rückt, was Gaming über WLAN betrifft, auf
jeden Fall ein Stück näher.
Das muss man schon sagen.
Und noch ein anderes Problem löst der Router, und zwar kennen wir das alle, nämlich, dass
der Akku schneller leer geht, als uns lieb ist und wenn wir das Handy überhaupt nicht
benutzen.
Aha.
Und der SpeedBot Pro Plus, der versetzt das WLAN Modul, nicht das ganze Handy, aber das
WLAN Modul in eine Art Standby Modus, wenn gerade keine Daten übertragen werden.
Das macht das Handy doch von sich aus.
Das muss doch, das muss doch der, also bin ich jetzt, vielleicht bin ich da auch nicht
auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es bei Wi-Fi 6 neue Stromsparmechanismen gibt, aber generell WLAN Modul abschalten,
das machen doch alle Smartphones schon die letzten 5 Jahre.
Das ist doch übrigens auch das Problem, warum du iPhones nicht gescheit tracken kannst.
Wenn du nämlich iPhones tracks, wenn du Presence Detection daheim machen willst mit einem iPhone,
dann hast du das Problem, dass das iPhone permanent in Standby geht und du deswegen
denkst, oh der Typ hat das Haus verlassen.
Das ist ja praktisch.
Ich mein, vielleicht bringt das was zusätzlich mit Wi-Fi 6 noch, kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen,
weiß ich nicht.
Aber irgendwie bezweifle ich, dass das nennenswerte Auswirkungen hat.
Das funktioniert auch mit Geräten, die...
Es ist ja nicht falsch, was sie erzählen.
Exakt so ist es, ist natürlich der Idealfall, dass das Gerät auch Wi-Fi 6 hat, denn dann
kann man natürlich das volle Potential der Fähigkeiten des Routers ausnutzen, aber der
Router ist klug, der erkennt die verschiedenen Protokolle, die wurden ihm einprogrammiert,
deswegen kann er das unterscheiden und kann eben alles das, was auch über die anderen
Wi-Fi-Protokolle möglich ist, entsprechend umsetzen.
Das Ding sieht so kacke aus.
Ergo, man braucht kein Wi-Fi 6, es hat noch mit den anderen Wi-Fi-Protokollen...
Das sieht so kacke aus.
...und ja, kluges kleines Ding, kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Was wir am Testen tatsächlich gemerkt haben, ist, dass das Einstecken der Kabel ein bisschen
frimmelig ist.
Wir sind nämlich hier unten und damit nicht so gut zu erreichen.
Also mal eben Kabelreihen rausstecken, das funktioniert nicht so gut.
Da muss man ein bisschen Geduld haben.
Wisst ihr, mit was die tatsächlich punkten könnten, wenn es 2,5G-Anschlüsse wären?
Das wäre tatsächlich cool.
Glaube ich aber nicht.
Aber für 400 Euro könnte man das sogar erwarten.
Hier auf der Rückseite, man hat hier direkt noch USB-Anschlüsse und kann also seinen
Controller direkt aus der Kabel reinstecken.
Das ist ja ein bisschen komisch, aber es ist ein bisschen komisch, aber es ist ein bisschen
komisch, dass man das so einfach aus der Kabel reinstecken kann.
Also seinen Controller direkt zum Laden anschließen.
Würdest du denn sagen, dass sich das Gerät für jeden Haushalt lohnt?
Oh, das finde ich eine sehr gute Frage.
Die Wi-Fi 6-Technologie und halt die Funktionen des Routers, die kommen erst dann richtig
zu tragen, wenn der Router so richtig was zu tun hat halt.
Genau, wenigstens ist er fair und sagt das.
Das ist das, was ich auch gerade gemeint habe.
Die ganzen QoS-Sachen bringen nämlich gar nichts.
Normalerweise, in 99% der Fällen oder bei vielen nie.
Teilnehmer im Netzwerk sind eine hohe Netzauslastung da.
Genau, sonst bringt das nämlich gar nichts.
Ich habe drei Kinder, die alle gamen wollen.
Nein.
Meine Frau oder mein Mann ist gerade eben in einer Videokonferenz und es läuft irgendwo
noch der Fernseher über IPTV.
Selbst dann, selbst dann reicht das noch nicht.
Dann ist halt eine hohe Last auf dem Netz und der Router hat eben halt wirklich die Fähigkeit,
diese Kommunikation optimal zu regeln und das kommt eben nur in einer solchen Situation
wirklich zum Tragen.
Natürlich hat man über Wi-Fi 6 eben die Stelle.
Aber wenigstens sagt das, wenigstens sagt das.
Internetverbindung, aber da kann der Router halt nicht zeigen, was er drauf hat.
Das Positive daran ist natürlich, wir haben Luft nach oben.
Wir können in die Zukunft blicken, wenn die Seiten aufwendiger werden, wenn die Anwendungen
auf Smart TVs etc. aufwendiger werden, wenn die drei Kindern irgendwann da sind und eben
auch gamen wollen, dann weiß ich, ich kann ganz entspannt sitzen.
Also wenn ich drei Kinder hätte, hätte ich glaube ich andere Probleme als QoS Gaming
Router.
Ganz im Ernst.
Also ich würde natürlich erstmal alles dransetzen, dass es gar nicht zu den drei Kindern kommt,
okay?
Aber wenn die da mal da sind, hätte ich glaube ich andere Probleme.
Aber der Speedboard Pro macht das schon.
Ein anderes Thema, was heutzutage auch Standard ist, ist natürlich auch Smart Home.
Du bist mit deinem Toaster im Internet, deine Waschmaschine lässt dich nur noch über App
steuern.
Ist der Router...
Du hast keine Ahnung, wovon du sprichst.
Ich glaub, ich kauf ihr das nicht ab, dass sie schon mal einen Toaster im Internet gesehen
hat.
Und dass ihre Waschmaschine, ich glaub's ihr einfach nicht.
Der Router darauf vorbereitet.
Ich mein, ich hab schon viel Smart Home-Krempel, ja?
Und mein Toaster ist auch nicht im Internet.
Ja, absolut.
Also die meisten Smart Homes kommunizieren mit dem Standard, der nennt sich Zigbee.
Und das kann unser Speedboard Pro Plus problemlos verwalten.
Andere Router dagegen möchten zum Beispiel oft nur mit ihren hauseigenen Smart Homes
kommunizieren.
Das stimmt, da hat sie recht.
Wobei Zigbee, Z-Wave da so ein bisschen sich Hand in Hand geben.
Wobei ich für Zigbee, ganz ehrlich, da würd ich das natürlich nicht über so einen Router
machen, da würd ich mir einen Zigbee Stick kaufen und kann das deutlich besser integrieren
als sowas in so einem Speedboard-Router.
Zu Hause ist ein gutes Stichwort, wir schauen jetzt nämlich mal bei SK Gaming vorbei.
Jawoll.
Die haben das Ding nämlich schon im Einsatz.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen in der SK Magenta Facility in Köln.
Hier trainieren unsere SK-...
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die... Ist das schon lange so, dass Telekom und SK Gaming
da irgendwelche Sponsoring-Geschichten haben?
Ich hab von SK wirklich lange nichts mehr gesehen und gehört.
Oh, das ist ja mal richtig Hardcom-Agent da hier.
Das Team, das da rum auch mit den Spielern arbeitet, wir gehen mal hier lang, schauen
wir uns das mal an.
Die spielen LoL, oder?
Spielen die LoL?
Hier ist aktuell gerade das Prime-Team.
Da, da.
Das leckert vielleicht das Team, der Marc reizt sich grad vor und...
Ja.
Ob die über WLAN spielen, ich bezweifle es.
Wir sind hier auf die Speedport Pro plus Gaming-Variante und sind damit äußerst zufrieden.
Hi Martin, schön, dass es geklappt hat.
Ja, hi Julia.
Ja, wir haben den Ruder ja grad schon in Action gesehen und euch beim Spielen zugeschaut.
Was spielt ihr denn da so und was macht ihr sonst noch so im Teamhaus?
Ja, was machen wir hier?
Also in der Eskar Magenta Facility Köln, das ist quasi an unserer Firmenzentrale mit
angedockt, haben wir eine Begegnungsstätte für Spieler errichtet, in dem maßgeblich
natürlich unsere Spieler trainieren, aber sich halt vorbereiten.
Das ist äußerst Magenta, oder?
Wir streiten für Wettkämpfe, teilweise auch Wettkämpfe von hier aus bestreiten in verschiedenen
Sibilen, sei es von Computer-Stationen, überall.
Ja, warum haben die den Teamhaus, weil man da besser trainieren kann mit den Leuten zusammen.
Das hat schon seinen Sinn, das hat ja, sag mal so jede größere E-Sport-Organisation hat
teilweise, wenn du dir größere anguckst, mehrere Häuser oder große Häuser.
Tablets, Phones oder halt auch Konsolen und ja im Zentrum steht natürlich, steht diese
Gaming-Station, aber wir haben darum auch alles gebaut und zur Verfügung gestellt,
was so ein Gamer hervorragend...
Ich will nicht überwählern, ich wette mit euch, ich will nicht überwählern, warum sollten
sie?
Das fängt halt an damit, dass die Spieler, dass wir eine Köchin hier vor Ort haben,
die sich am Frühstück, Mittag und Abendessen kümmert.
Was?
Warum eine Köchin?
Warum kein Koch?
Sexismus?
Was hier los anzeige ist raus.
Dass da keine Wünsche offen bleiben, Ernährung ist ein zentraler Schandteil in dem, ja so
wie wir mit unseren Spielern umgehen und das was, wie wir halt auch an professionellen
Spieler heutzutage wahrnehmen und halt auch ja mitunterstützen möchten, darüber hinaus
haben wir einen Gym bei uns, einen Keller, das heißt auch die...
Okay, die machen jetzt ein bisschen Promotion für ihr Teamhouse, verstehe.
Dafür ist es gesorgt, die...
Ey man, schick ist es, ne?
Also ich muss sagen, Style, also das Teamhouse ist stylischer als der WLAN-Router.
Muckis punden möchte, aber uns ist natürlich sehr, sehr wichtig, dass eine gesunde Balance
zwischen Geist und Körper auch einfach bei jedem in irgendeiner Form mit verinnerlicht
wird und deswegen haben wir eine Fitnessstudie bei uns im Keller mit Laufbändern, also mit
Cardio-Möglichkeiten, mit natürlich auch Gewichten.
Wir haben...
Ja gut, halt mit dem Router ja nichts zu tun jetzt, ne?
... dass man auch einfach mal nach einem sehr, sehr anstrengenden Session sich...
Da!
Habt ihr den Router gesehen?
Der ist bestimmt hier in der Procoli irgendwo.
... mal nach einem sehr, sehr anstrengenden Session sich ein bisschen entspannt zurücklegen
kann und ja, das natürlich alles trotzdem mit dem Ziel, dass der Spieler sich am Ende
des Tages natürlich bestmöglich vorbereiten kann auf den Wettkampf, aber natürlich sich
auch sehr, sehr wohl fühlt in der Begegnung mit dem Spiel.
Ja und gerade ihr als E-Sports-Organisatoren seid ihr voll drauf angewiesen, dass beim
Game kein Lack dazwischenkommt.
Ja klar, also das ist so wichtig, wie...
Das ganze Video ist so gestellt, äh, oh!
... der geschnürte Schuh beim Fußballer wahrscheinlich, ne, wenn der nicht sitzt, dann kann man auch
nicht spielen.
Insofern, das für uns absolut essenziell, wir vertrauen darauf, dass wir eine stabile
Leitung haben.
Klar, jetzt nicht wie jeder zuhause, haben wir auch sicherlich noch mal eine Back-up-Leitung,
die irgendwo einspringen kann, auch danke an die Telekom an der Stelle, dass wir das
haben.
Also wenn jemand gesponsert ist von der Telekom, dann würde ich auch erwarten, dass er ordentlich
angeschlossen ist, alles andere wäre ja nun wirklich lächerlich, wozu muss ich von der
Telekom sponsern lassen, wenn dann das Internet nicht funktioniert?
Wir müssen wirklich auch sagen, die Erfahrung mit dem neuen Speedport Gaming, mit der Edition,
zeigt wirklich, dass wir da wesentlich mehr Stabilität drin haben.
Die haben im Leben nicht darüber gespielt, lange Zeit, die haben ihr Netzwerk-Setup,
die haben ihr Zeug da aufgebaut, die haben vielleicht mal zwei Leute an den neuen Speedport
Gaming, aber die haben doch jetzt nicht gesagt, hey Jungs, wir spielen letzte Woche über
WLAN und testen das neue Speedport Gaming, im Leben nicht.
Jetzt kleinere Ausfälle, die ab und zu mal passieren, sowas wie Spikes oder so, sind
wesentlich weniger wahrnehmbar, die Wi-Fi 6-Möglichkeiten.
Ihr spielt im Leben nicht über WLAN, ich wette mit euch, die spielen nicht über WLAN.
Es gibt sehr, sehr wenige Routergeräte, die das mittlerweile können, darauf vertrauen
wir auch.
Welche Routergeräte können was?
Ausfälle, die ab und zu mal passieren, sowas wie Spikes oder so, sind wesentlich weniger
wahrnehmbar, es ist so, dass die Wi-Fi 6-Möglichkeiten uns halt auch ein bisschen...
Das stimmt, das stimmt, es gibt tatsächlich wenige Wi-Fi 6-Geräte, man muss aber auch
sagen, es gibt nicht so viele Wi-Fi 6-Endgeräte, also es gibt ja, es gibt wenige Wi-Fi 6-Router,
es gibt aber auch noch nicht so viele Wi-Fi 6-Endgeräte.
In die Hände spielt, es gibt sehr, sehr wenige Routergeräte, die das mittlerweile können,
darauf vertrauen wir auch, dass man da wirklich immer mit der besten Technik ausgestattet.
Das heißt, der Router erfüllt eigentlich alle seine Zwecke, wenn man überhaupt nicht
merkt, ob man ein Router in der Form gar nicht wahrnehmen möchte, also man kann es nicht
gerne anschauen und man braucht sich natürlich auch so ein Gerät auf den Betrieb zu nehmen
und die Features, die man nicht in der Hand hat.
Ja, klar, also ein Router möchte man eigentlich in der Form gar nicht wahrnehmen, man kann
es nicht gerne anschauen und man braucht sich eigentlich auch so ein Gerät auf den
Betrieb zu nehmen und die Features, die man nicht in der Hand hat.
Besser.
Wenn man da mal raufschaut und auch ein bisschen Sicherheitsgefühl, ein besseres Sicherheitsgefühl
zu kriegen, so einen Ping-Test zu machen und solche Geschichten, finde ich auch ganz
spannend, aber im besten Fall, wie beim Shiri, den lässt man irgendwie mitlaufen, aber hat
ihn auch irgendwie nicht so auf dem Schirm und wird im Idealfall auch gar nicht von ihm
in irgendeiner Form gestört.
Ja super, vielen Dank, schön, dass du Zeit für uns hattest.
Danke, wir und euch auch, ganz gut.
Also ich sehe den Zinder voll nicht.
Also ich finde, der Router ist perfekt, wenn mehrere Personen in einem Haushalt leben,
also zum Beispiel Familien oder WGs oder auch Firmen und durch die hohen Reichweiten ist
es auch für größere Gebäude oder Häuser mit Terrasse, mit Garten umso besser geeignet.
Also wenn ich jetzt in die Zukunft schaue, meine Jungs ein bisschen älter, ich glaube
bei uns führt kein Weg dran vorbei, dass wir uns den Speedpod Pro Plus kaufen.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Hingegen für Einzelpersonen, die den Router bzw. deren Internetleistung nur in der Freizeit
nutzen, ist das Ganze ein bisschen hochpreisig, nicht 399 Euro.
Da würde es reichen, wenn man zu einem etwas günstigen Modell greift.
Ja, da stimme ich euch auf jeden Fall zu.
Ja, 399 Euro ist natürlich ziemlich hochpreisig.
Das ist ordentlich.
Aber gerade aus meiner Sicht als Gamer, also in Bezug auf das Hobby, kann ich nur sagen,
dass eben alle Geräte, die eben einen besonderen Zweck in der Richtung erfüllen, eben recht
hochpreisig sind.
Das Ding sieht, wie das blinkt.
Gaming-Maus, die besonders präzise ist, wodurch ich meine Figur besser bewegen kann, professioneller
Artikel wie das Stream Deck oder meine Beleuchtung, die ich jetzt hier verwende, oder ähnliches.
Ja, vom Stream Deck hast du ja wenigstens auch was.
Dass einfach da dann auch wirklich gut den Zweck erfüllt und da auch Qualität nötig
ist.
Also mal im Ernst, wenn ich wirklich gute WLAN-Versorgung bei mir daheim haben will,
dann nehme ich nicht ein Speedpod Pro und stelle das irgendwo hin.
Da mache ich in sinnvollem Abstand, an sinnvollen Locations, da wo es auch die Infrastruktur
zulässt, mache ich einfach 2, 3, 4, je nach Haus, je nach Bauweise, je nach Beton oder
was auch immer, 2-4 Access Points hin.
Das muss auch noch nicht immer Wi-Fi 6 sein, wie gesagt, es ist ja nicht so, als ist das
jetzt das Allheilmittel gegen alles und dann ist gut, dann habe ich super Abdeckung im
ganzen Haus, unter dem Dach, im Keller, auf der Terrasse und hast keine Probleme.
Das ist, finde ich, die bessere Investition von 400 Euro als das Teil, da billiger bist
du nicht wirklich, wenn du dir gescheite Access Points kaufst.
Es ist auch für Firmen geil, genau, oh je, morgen, ich weiß schon, morgen auf der Arbeit
kommt der Erste und sagt, reißt alle Access Points raus, jetzt kommt der Telekom Speedpod
Pro.
Was sind Access Points, so Dinger mit Antennen drinnen, mit denen sich dein Handy verbinden
kann, ins WLAN?
Egal, was die Technologien betrifft, um eben eine möglichst hohe Netzauslastung abzudecken
und dementsprechend schnelle Internetverbindungen zu ermöglichen, von daher, er kann alles,
was er können muss, er sieht wie gesagt mega aus, finde ich, also ich kann mich glaube
ich auch überhaupt nicht von ihm trennen.
Es stimmt ja, es stimmt ja alles, es ist zwar ein bisschen geschönt, aber es stimmt ja
alles, was die sagen, aber eine Sache kann ich überhaupt nicht zustimmen, dass es schön
aussieht.
Ich finde, es sieht überhaupt nicht schön aus.
Na ja, sag ich mal, sprich nichts dagegen, muss man sich letzten Endes überlegen oder
ob man dann nicht doch ein günstigeres Modell, muss aber auch sagen, dass jeder Standardrouter,
wenn man ihn jetzt einfach so im Laden kauft, auch im Bereich 150 bis 200 Euro liegt, also
von daher.
Ja, wenn man sich so ein komisches Speedpod Ding kauft, Speedpod, das ist ja aber auch
ein Oper der Fritzbox, man muss ja auch dazusagen, das sind ja eigentlich gar keine Router im
eigentlichen Sinne, das sind Multifunktionsgeräte, die Fritzbox übrigens auch, das sind Multifunktionsgeräte
mit, die unter anderem eine, sagen wir mal so, noch nicht mal sonderlich advanced Routering-Funktionalität
bieten.
Also für alles, was man so daheim machen will, reicht das natürlich, aber das, was
man heute Router nennt, ist ja eigentlich ein Multifunktionsgerät mit einem Accesspoint
drinne, mit einem DSL-Modem drinne, mit einem Switch drinne, mit einem Router drinne, mit
Nass-Funktionalität drinne, mit einer Deckt-Basis-Station drinne, mit zig Sachen, ja, das ist ja eigentlich
nur ein ganz kleiner Teil davon.
Zuverhältnismäßig und wie gesagt, falsch macht man auf jeden Fall am Ende nichts.
Ja, aber es gibt ein bisschen viel Geld dabei, wie Manuel, dann ist der Speedpod Pro Plus
in der Gaming Edition sicher das beste Gerät für euch.
Schaut doch mal auf den Telekom-Shop vorbei.
Na dann mal ran an die Konsole zum Zocken.
Oh, cringe!
Das war's auch schon mit dieser Episode aus dem Tech-Tag.
Dann mal ran an die Konsole zum Zocken aufgeben.
Wie sind denn so die Kommentare hier, zeig mal her.
Ah, da ist er.
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, niemand interessiert sich für den Telekom-Router, oder?
Ich meine, auf Twitter hat es auch keinen gejuckt.
Es ist eigentlich komplett irrelevant, oder?
Mal gucken, was Twitter dazu so sagt.
Nö, also ich glaube, man kann da wirklich ruhig und gemissens sagen, juckt keine Sau.
Juckt wirklich keine Sau.
Hallo, das ist alles, was man dazu findet.
Man findet dazu nichts.
Nee, das ist doch echt sinnlos.
Gut, aber wieder was gelernt, BSS Coloring, alles klar.
Das weiß ich Bescheid.
Na, Gaming Edition heißt bei denen, es hat ein bisschen RGB geplinkt und das war's eigentlich.
Was daran ist jetzt eigentlich genau Gaming Edition?
Es hat RGB geplinkt und ein bisschen QoS Geschichten, was aber auch Geräte vor 15 Jahren schon hatten.
Und es ist teuer, was genau ist da jetzt die Gaming Edition dran?
Schon in Hochwasser gesehen vom Bauern, jetzt können wir es am Wochenende angucken.
Übrigens, Wi-Fi 6 ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie man Produkte gut benennen kann.
Wer ist so Big Brain und kennt den richtigen Namen von Wi-Fi 6?
Weiß das jemand?
Also ich kann's euch sagen, der korrekte Begriff für Wi-Fi 6 ist IEEE, das heißen sie aber
alle.
Genau.
Richtig, Chat weiß es, 802.11ax, 802.11ax oder die coolen Leute sagen wahrscheinlich
0.11ax oder nur noch ax oder, also diese Sachen werden ja gerne abgekürzt.
Was sagen die coolen Leute dazu, die nicht Wi-Fi 6 sagen wollen, die Big Brainiger klingen
wollen ax wahrscheinlich, einfach nur noch.
Ja, das ist übrigens ein gutes Beispiel entgegen USB, wie man Produkte gescheit benennen kann,
weil was ist griffiger, Wi-Fi 6 oder 802.11ax, IEEE, ja ich weiß, aber das sagt auch niemand
davor.
Ah ok, mein iPhone 11 kann's also nicht, ich hab nämlich kein 11er Pro.
Na gut, was kann man jetzt real, ok jetzt mal ernsthaft, was kann man da jetzt großartig
Negatives über den Telekom Router sagen?
Eigentlich, gut wir haben ihn nicht ausprobiert, also was mir sehr negativ auffällt ist natürlich
erstmal der Preis, wo man sich denkt, warum muss das so teuer sein und dass es mega hässlich
aussieht, stört mich nicht, aber bei einem Gerät, wo man jetzt extra explizit wirbt
für die Optik, das ist dann so kacke aus, oh nein ich will das nicht nochmal aufmachen,
MonkaS, das verstehe ich nicht, ansonsten es wirkt halt irgendwie nicht, es hat für
mich wenig Existenzberechtigung, der SideTrack ist real ja, ich bin auch so low brain, ich
weiß gar nicht inwieweit, aber gut wir haben jetzt zumindest aufgehört, wo das Einlesen
schon funktioniert.
Schnell und stabil sollten eigentlich alle diese Geräte sein, es sei denn Telekom verkackts,
das hat nichts mit Gaming WLAN zu tun, Mesh, ok also ich würde jetzt auch sagen, also
gerade im Heimbereich, das ist jetzt nicht so, da bist du jetzt nicht so drauf angewiesen,
dass du irgendwie durchs Haus laufen kannst, VoIP telefonieren und ohne jeglichen Verbindungsabbruch
da irgendwie, das ist so nice to have, aber das ist jetzt nichts, was mich jetzt so wahnsinnig
schockt.
Ne Mesh hat mit Gaming nichts zu tun, ich meine ihr wisst ich bin jetzt nicht der super
Netzwerk Pro, aber ein bisschen beschäftige ich mich ja da auch, also meines Wissens nach
ist ja der große Vorteil von Mesh, also ich muss ich anders anfangen, also du konntest
ja schon immer mehrere Exist Points mit der gleichen SSID betreiben und dann hat sich
in der Regel das Smartphone den besten Access Point mit dem beispielsweise besten Empfang
rausgesucht und hat sich dazu verbunden, das geht ja schon ewig, das geht ja schon, keine
Ahnung, 10 Jahre oder so, so was diese Mesh Geschichte jetzt ausmacht ist unter anderem,
dass das Gerät und der Access Point die Übergabe besser managen können, also genau Roaming,
richtig, korrekt, du kannst die Übergabe von einem Access Point zum anderen Access Point
besser handeln, weil Access Point und Gerät sich da besser darüber abstimmen können,
das heißt du hast beispielsweise auch kein kurzes Laggen im VoIP Telefonat, wenn du von
einem Access Point zum anderen Access Point lädst und die Verbindung switcht, geht das
mittlerweile bei Android Geräten, wüsste nicht warum es nicht gehen soll, so und das
ist soweit ich weiß der große Vorteil von Mesh, ob man das jetzt daheim braucht, ja
keine Ahnung, es geht ja um Wi-Fi, es geht nicht irgendwie Roaming über Mobilfunk,
weiß nicht ob das Android damit Probleme hatte, keine Ahnung und der Backbone läuft zwischen
Access Points oft über ein anderes Frequenzband, damit dieses Repeater Problem weg ist, ok
das wusste ich nicht, das ist aber sinnvoll, Postchamp, auf was wartest, auf was Postchamp ihr?
Leute lasst uns mal ne Runde Postchampen zusammen, wir Postchampen mal ne Runde, auf gehts, was
heute schon die neuen Azubis getroffen, ich bin seit eineinhalb Jahren nicht mehr in der
Firma gewesen, keine Ahnung, ach ja und mit dem USB Controller Laden, ob das jetzt so
ein Vorteil ist, ich weiß ja nicht, wer lädt denn seinen Controller über den Router, naja
gut, wie auch immer, zack, so also, machen wir mal kurz Prograss weiter, zumindest jetzt
zu schauen ob das jetzt an sich noch funktioniert, was ich hier gebaut hab, Leute also es klappt,
der Chat wusste es gleich wieder und ich hab's dem Chat nicht geglaubt, ich hab's dem Chat
wieder nicht geglaubt, ich hab Critical Information geleckt, der Chat wusste es schon von Anfang
an, so siehst du, dass die Code funktioniert und jetzt kann ich mal ausprobieren, ob das
auch so funktioniert hätte wie vorher, das müsste eigentlich vorher so eigentlich auch
gehen jetzt, oh nein RIP, das muss man echt so machen, ok warum geht das dann sonst mit
Videos, naja gut, ok aber sag mal so, dass die Code funktioniert, jetzt kann ich ja mal
probieren, ob ich irgendwas sinnvolles decoded bekomme, so kann ich das mal wieder löschen,
an sich wissen wir, dass die Code funktioniert jetzt, so und in diesem Frame steht jetzt
mal eine Audiodaten drinne oder wie, Frame Samples, NB Samples, was haben wir, Number
of Audio Samples per Channel Described, 1024 Samples haben wir da drin, ok und das kann
man damit jetzt einfach abspielen, NB Samples, da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt, ob man die
Audio Geschichten jetzt einfach damit abspielen kann, übrigens das Beispiel hat gesagt,
es kann sein, dass wir mehrere Frames bekommen, probier ich jetzt mal aus, ob wir mehrere
Frames bekommen, das ist How to Bauer Endlosschleife, ach ich will mal was gucken, sonst muss ich
abbrechen, ah Mist, ich war zu langsam, ist ok, ist gut, du musst bei der Alloc Kontext
Variable glaub noch die Code Parameter kopieren, Parameter zu Kontext, ah ja weil das ist die
neue Variante, so müsste es eigentlich, genau das probier ich jetzt mal aus, warte mal wo
sind wir denn, hier, Par Kontext, ah, Code Parameter zu Kontext, ach ne ich muss zuerst
sagen Alloc Kontext, ich kann da mal schreiben Kontext, sowas da und dann nochmal den, ok
warum auch immer und jetzt sage ich das, Code Kontext und jetzt nochmal Parameter, Stream
Code Parameter, so jetzt funktioniert es hoffentlich auch wieder, ja minus 11 Max meine Güte, so
es wird jetzt richtig, jetzt wird es richtig hübsch, gut wir brauchen nicht mehrere Frames,
das ist Schwachsinn, das decoded immer nur ein Frame, das decoded immer nur ein Frame,
ok das funktioniert und jetzt kann ich die Samples ausgeben, also N-Audio brauchen wir
jetzt, N-Audio, N-Audio, da muss ich erstmal hilf, N-Audio, play, play waff, examples,
examples please, examples, ich will waff, ich will on the fly waff abspielen, N-Audio,
play waff, fight array, so, waff provider, raw source waff stream, alles klar das brauchen
wir jetzt, exquisite, Moment was, hab das zu toll, dass du gerade vorhin aufhattest,
mal vor einer Weile gemacht, falls du meinen kommentierten, wie kommentiert, warum ist
das kommentiert, nicht best practice, lieber gleich beim ersten mal so aussagekräftig programmieren,
dass man nicht kommentieren muss, oder, oder, Nassi Schneiderman Struktogramm malen, ja
das ist auch ok, vielleicht auch noch nen Papp, hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun aber
egal, und nen Gantt Diagramm, dann kann man sich sicher sein, dass es funktioniert, ach
ja und du solltest vielleicht noch nen ITIL Kurs machen und Scrum Master werden, dann
ist alles gut, aber nice, nice, ach guck mal da, audio decode frame, das ist ja C++,
das sehe ich ja jetzt erst, aber jeder wie Rammel, ne also, ich flame mir immer nur just
for fun da, ist ja ja, pack it, queue get, was ist denn das, ist das was von dir oder
ist das, ist das was von FFmpeg, das ist was von dir oder, ich boog mal, dass mir das
mal, ach das ist vom Tutorial, aber das ist nix von FFmpeg, ok, Moment, wir spielen das
jetzt ab hier, N Audio, ist das das richtige was ich hier hab, was ich hier gefunden hab,
N Audio 2.0, ja, zack, so wie ging das jetzt, raw source waff stream, Moment, ich will,
ich will, ich will nicht das nicht streamen, ich will permanent reinpipen, Moment, N Audio
play stream, buffert waff provider, ok, Demo, mit code blacks, wie alt ist denn der Kram
noch, WTF, buffern waff provider, äh, warum genau ist das jetzt broken, wa, was ist denn
jetzt, ich hab da nur, nur getpackaged installiert, what the, must be set to windows, ah, das
ist ok, wo mach ich das denn, warte mal, wo mach ich das denn, was, target platform must
be set to windows, was, ich, es geht nervlich rum hier, what the, ok, dann probier ich die
andere library mal aus, cscore, stream, ok, cscore stream waff, oh, memory stream, genau,
jetzt sag mal, kann ich nicht einfach sagen, spiel stream ab und gut ist, ich pipe einfach
neue samples rein und gut ist, WTF, was ist hier los, warum ist auch publisches sound up
spielen schon wieder kompliziert, as fuck, play waff stream, kennst du geruda linux,
was, nein, sagt mir nix, nachdem eine waff datei erfolgreich aus einer, Moment, da gibt
es was eingebautes, assistive media, das ist, das ist windows only, ne, das ist dot net
dabei, ok, ich glaube, an audio dot net core, was, was muss ich da, was muss ich da machen,
dot net support, oh ne, das hat kein dot net 5 support, rip, hm, oder doch, n audio core
brauch ich, ok, auch gut, dann nimm ich n audio core, ich will doch, ich will doch einfach
nur waff, ich will einfach nur sound up spielen, ok, haben wir es jetzt, also, dann legen wir
mal hier aus, was buffert, buffert stream, buffert wave provider, was, alter leut, lasst
mich doch einfach, lasst mich doch einfach audio datei abspielen, wie, wie verwendet
man den kram dann hier, example, example, docks, stream, stream, raw, raw source wave stream,
quickmaps, alles klar, raw source wave stream, und das in memory stream, ok, das ist kein
problem, das kann ich machen, of course, of course, easy, easy, memory stream, so, was,
was ist raw, eh, waffer, brauch man net, kann man doch reinschreiben, gleich, using commons
abspeichern, sample rate, sample rate müsste ich ja eigentlich rausbekommen, aus dem codec,
codec, sample, sample rate, genau, ja, 44, ok, passt, ist doch gut, memory leak incoming,
auf jeden fall, so, sample rate, wahrscheinlich, pass mal auf, gleich gibt es irgendwie e-rape
im stream wegen, weil ich irgendwie Mist eingestellt habe, ok, raw source wave stream, ok, und
wie geht es jetzt weiter, and now we can play wave stream just like it was, ok, muss ich
das in einem extra thread machen, nee, noch schreibe ich ja nix rein, noch sollte, wie,
ich kann nix ausgeben, wo ist denn der Sinn davon, wenn ich nix ausgeben kann, da brauche
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich die windows-only-library für canassine, haben wir mal so big brain
time, man kann doch mit rider sachen such das mal in nuget, ja, jetzt brauche ich die,
jetzt muss ich das wieder auf windows-only stellen, wie auch immer ich das überhaupt
mache in den settings, so, mal gucken, ob das, ok, ich teste mal, ob das zumindest nicht
abkackt, so, rs, also play gibt es hier nicht, source stream, so, und von der idee kann ich
doch meine samples jetzt einfach in den memory stream schreiben, ich habe schon lange nix
an mit streams gemacht, right, genau, genau, jetzt kommt das in den memory stream, und
wo kriege ich jetzt meine audio samples her, wie hast du denn angefangen sie scharp zu
lernen mit dotnet 2, wo alles noch auf, also zwischen dotnet 1 1 und dotnet 2, dotnet 2
gab es schon, und das war 2003 oder so, habe ich damit angefangen, so, wie kriege ich denn
jetzt überhaupt meine bytes da raus, frame, source samples, data wahrscheinlich, data,
oh fuck, kriege ich da jetzt ein byte array raus, jawoll, bam, bytes, ach nee, das geht
ja nicht, moment, wie macht man da jetzt nochmal ein byte, so, ne, bytes, und die länge,
die länge ist, ähm, frame, data, nee, ähm, count, length, ach, moment, wie war das jetzt
nochmal, moment, ich muss mal in dem anderen nachgucken, weiß nicht mehr was die länge
war, ja, der overlay champ, ja, video frame, die länge ist, was da, moment, wo, wo, moment,
wo, wo, hä, wie weiß ich denn jetzt wie lang der ganze kram ist, ich mache jetzt einfach
mal 1024, ich meine es sind 1024 samples steht da drinnen, ich habe mal 1024, so, das jetzt
funktioniert, moment, das ist jetzt, das krackt jetzt ab, bam, was, das verstehe ich jetzt
aber nicht, wo, was hat er jetzt für ein Problem, was hat er jetzt für ein Schmerzen,
aber wahrscheinlich sind da weniger drinnen, was weiß ich, woher weiß, woher soll ich
denn wissen wie lang data ist, da steht das irgendwo, ich meine hier verwende ich das
ja auch, data, ja, hier ist es line size, aber das ist, das ist ja video, was weiß
ich, wie groß, wie groß so ein, keine Ahnung, random int, wisst ihr was, was wir das jetzt
machen, so, mal gucken ob es dabei schon abkackt, ne, eins, bam, obje, wo, moment, wo, wo kackt
der ab, äh, monka, wo, wo, wozu, das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht, wo ist der jetzt abgekackt,
ich bin auch mit dem rider debugger ein bisschen auf Kriegsfuß, wo ist, wo ist der abgekackt
jetzt, ah hier, copy to beim kopieren in die spare nester abgekackt, monka weh, wie kriege
ich denn die länge davon raus, ok, av frame, waffdata, what, mona gas, mona gas, mona
gas, wie machen die, ich hab doch hier ein Beispiel, ich hab doch hier irgendwie ein
Beispiel gehabt, hier ist das Beispiel hier, so, was machen die da, receive frame, so und
was machen die jetzt mit dem frame, get bytes per, aaah, ne, oder, get bytes per sample
data size, sample f, was, das ist echt so krass kryptisch, teilweise ffmpeg, receive
frame, frame, was macht der damit jetzt, frame, number samples, ach, das ist ja auch noch
pro channel, ok, ok, ich glaube, ich glaube ich, ich check es halbwegs, ich mach jetzt
einfach ne waffdatei und wenn die sich abspielen lässt, alles gut, ähm, brauchen ne waffdatei
irgendeinen header, dass die funktioniert, ähm, so, ich schreib das, ich schreib das
einfach hin, ok, number samples ist klar, das ergibt Sinn, frame, nb, samples, äh,
was, was genau hat der jetzt für Probleme, so war, so, das ist jetzt 1024 und jetzt die
nächste Schleife ist Anzahl an channels, ja, das ist bei mir immer 2, channels ist immer
2, also kann ich im Prinzip gleich schon sagen, 2, sind immer 2 channels, oder aber, oder
aber, mach nen switch mit dem codec type, äh, achso, du meinst jetzt was anderes,
ja, gut die channels, channels sollten ja meistens 2 sein, aber ich kanns ja auch sagen,
ich kann ja auch sagen, codec, context, channels, das müsste ja auch funktionieren, du programmierst
noch nicht so lang, ne, noch nicht so lang, so, ähm, was zum, alter wie funktioniert
das, was machen, was machen die jetzt hier für big brain Dinger, also das ist das ja
im Prinzip was mich interessiert, warte mal, ist das hier, ist das, moment mal, das ist
ja, das ist ja C Beispiel code, ist das irgendeine pointer magic, dass der quasi data, dass
der anfängt beim channel und dann als offset data size macht, ok, was ist data size, data
size ist das, mein chibait hat eben gar keiner mitbekommen, oder, der war so, der war so
versteckt eingebaut, was ist, wie funktioniert das, ffmpeg, was, get bytes per sample, ok,
alles klar, ich hab, ich hab keinen plan, aber ich mein, hey, es funktioniert immerhin,
so, und jetzt data size, frame, ok, data, so, channel, das da, und da, ach so, das müssen
wir, das ist, das, das kann es ja nicht direkt ausgeben, oh bytes, zack, das da, und jetzt
ist es, moment, gibt doch keinen Sinn, dass die Ome es verkehrt, eventuell geht das, ach,
ich krieg das schon hin, ich krieg das schon hin, was hat er jetzt für schmerzen, ah,
ja, was, ja, gut, meinetwegen, realmax, dankeschön für den sub, was ist das Ziel audio zeug
auslösen, außer video datei, so, so, und data size, weiß ich jetzt, ist, so, das, ok,
data size ist, wie lang das byte array ist, also kann ich jetzt sagen, was weiß ich, das
ist irgendwie, so was, byte, so, jetzt dann den pointer, und jetzt, das da, so, mal gucken,
ob es jetzt crashet, äh, nein, anscheinend nicht, gucken, ob es der Meinung ist, dass
das alles passt, hier, data size ist vier, ok, meinetwegen, ich sag nix, es passt, wenn
es, wenn es, wir wissen ja, wir wissen ja alle, wenn es kompiliert, dann funktioniert
es prinzipiell, immer, ok, ok, so, das sieht doch eigentlich schon mal ganz gut aus, jetzt
muss ich es nur noch schaffen, abzuspielen, den sound, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt dieses
komische Beispiel hier nehmen, äh, example, wo waren die examples jetzt, hä, ich hatte
doch eben irgendwo ein example, wo das, wo das drinnen stand, mit output, äh, wo hab
ich denn das jetzt hin, oh, keine Ahnung mehr, wo hab ich denn jetzt hin, wo, die hatten
doch examples hier, bin ich jetzt, example, ach hier, samples, ist es doch, Moment, das
ist das falsche repo, ich hatte doch eben ein Beispiel für streaming, ach hier, ja,
so, und jetzt kann ich den Krempel abspielen, na, noch kann nix passieren, noch, noch ist
ja im output nix drinne, overlay, ja hier hab ich ja noch drin steht, gut, was müsste
man da jetzt einbinden, dass das mit dem abspielen funktioniert, N-Audio, alles klar, jetzt sagt
er mir wieder, ich muss das auf Windows stellen, ok, wie um alles in der Welt stelle ich das
auf Windows, gibt's da irgendwie den, irgendwie ein Setting für, Target Platform must be set
to Windows, ok, Target Platform, wo setze ich die Target Platform, hier drinnen, wo macht
man das, in der Projektdatei kann man es bestimmt mit, mit irgendeinem xml-Gedöns eintragen,
haben die aber nicht hier irgendwie ein, irgendwas wo man das einstellen kann, Rider, Target
Platform, Platform Target, ja, hast du es gesehen, Target Framework, Output Time, echt,
ach so, ne, ne, das ist das CPU Architektur, das stimmt, ne, ne, das brauchen wir nicht,
ne, das war was anderes, wie, wie, wie, wie macht man das jetzt, Target, ok, Content Core
Target Platform, ja schön, gib mir das natürlich, ich brauch das unbedingt immer auf Deutsch,
dass man das besser versteht, ja, und wo, und wo, hier, du musst von.NET 5 auf 4.8,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, Quatsch, garantiert nicht, das wäre total bescheuert, wenn ich uralt
auf 4.8 nehmen müsste, ok, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man das macht, wir suchen jetzt
einfach mal nach der Fehlermeldung, so, how to resolve error, Microsoft, hilf uns, Minus
Windows soll ich dran, was, ich häng da jetzt Minus Windows dran, das ist ja, das ist ja
kein Ding, dann machen wir es halt voneinander, Terminal,.NET Run, geht, äh, Moment, wir
sind ja unter Windows, CD, Playchamp,.NET Run, gut, Minus Windows, ob das jetzt geht,
garantiert nicht, usually include Minus Windows, ach so, in a Target Framework Property, ok,
mein Gott, ist das Monarch S, funktioniert, ja, ok, ok, ok, hier, Target Frameworks, Target
Frameworks, vielleicht kann man Frameworks umstellen hier drin, oder ich muss es schließen
und dann von Hand editieren, Properties, hier, guck mal, Framework, Framework, highly komfortabel
das alles, sehts, sehts jemand, Framework, steht, was steht im ersten Tab, wo, ach hier,
ah, guck mal da,.NET 5 Windows, Poggers, Alter, jawoll, bringt aber nichts, ah, jawoll,
guck mal, jetzt, Pog, was für ein FFM Pack-Paket, äh, das ist ein Rapper um das, um die C-Library,
ok mal gucken, ob der jetzt den Sound ab spielt, nein, macht er nicht, ok, Moment, macht
der überhaupt irgendwas, oder muss ich das als extra, extra Thread starten, mal gucken,
ob der überhaupt was macht, ja, funktioniert, ok, also von der Idee her, sollte er jetzt
was outputen, macht er aber nicht, aber der Playchamp, guck mal, der Playchamp ist angeblich,
ok, aber er macht was, er macht was, also er sollte, er sollte jetzt eigentlich, muss
ich dir irgendwie sagen, irgendwie Flash oder so, weiß ich nicht, ja, naja, Leute, ich glaub,
wir sind nicht so weit weg davon, dass das funktioniert, wenn das, wenn die FFM Pack-Sachen
Sinn ergeben, die ich hier mache, ich mein, das spielt den Memorystream ab, hast du schon
eine Waffdatei eingebunden, naja, hier, da, das ist ja mein Audio-Stream, also von der
Idee her sollte das so klappen, achso, Moment mal, hier, Channels 2, ich glaube, ich spiel
das falsch ab, ne, ich glaube, ich spiel das irgendwie falsch ab, ich glaube, ich sollte
mal eine Waffdatei so versuchen abzuspielen, ich glaube, bei dem End-Audio-Kram fehlt noch,
glaube ich, das glaube ich auch, ups, Playback-State, das braucht man ja eigentlich nicht, das ist
ja nur, Moment, warum, was machen die denn da, ich dachte, das ist nur zum Checken, ob
es dann mal fertig ist irgendwann, ich mein, ich pack das, seh was, ich pack das einfach
mal in den eigenen Thread, Task, Run, Take Wait, Programmierst du ein Audio-Converter,
nein, ich will einfach, einfach einfach nur eine Audio-Spur in einem Video abspielen,
das ist alles, Thresht der? Moment, ich glaube, ich bediene das falsch,
ich glaube, ich bediene das irgendwie falsch, das ist garantiert Layer 8 Problem, aber ich
hab keine Ahnung, ich mein, so spielt man ein Stream ab, ich mein, steht ja sogar hier,
achso, vielleicht sollte ich mal kurz gucken, was das für eine Bitrate hat, Codec, Context,
Bitrate, zeig mal her, eigentlich Bitrate, Schwachsinn, ich brauch, was ist denn das,
das ist, Abtast, nee, was ist denn das, Bits per Raw Sample, wahrscheinlich, Null, was
ist Frequenz, nee, das ist nicht die Frequenz, das ist, wie genau das Ganze ist, oder, hab
ich denn hier alles, ach 16 wird schon passen, im Zweifel kommt Rauschen raus, irgendwas
muss da doch rauskommen, warum ist, warum ist Playback, Du playst überhaupt nicht, lüg
nicht rum, einfach True, wir spielen jetzt komplett, ich check das, ich bediene das garantiert
falsch, zu dem Zeitpunkt ist da ja noch gar nichts drin, das ist garantiert Layer 8 Problem,
zu dem Zeitpunkt ist da ja noch gar nichts drin, kann ich da auch so, achso, ich kann
da auch so direkt reinschreiben, ich brauch den Memorystream gar nicht, ok, dann schreib
ich auch nicht in den Memorystream, warum muss ich denn den Memorystream überhaupt anlegen,
wenn ich direkt da reinschreiben kann, äh, haben wir da irgendwie mal ein ordentliches
Beispiel für, ok, ich muss da Stream, Waff, also ich muss ein gescheites Beispiel für
geben, ja, nee, nee, nee, Pfeil will ich nicht, ja, schöne Diagramme, Example, Example,
genau, so, was Binary, das ist doch was ganz was anderes, ok, why are you using N-Audio,
Alter, geh mal nicht auf den Sack, typische Forum-Antwort, was ist Forum, typische Forum-Antwort
wieder, ja, warum möchte man denn sowas machen, das ist ja Blödsinn, ok, ich bin zu 3-Head
zu checken, wie ich die Library verwende, das haben wir uns eben angeguckt, was, Code
China, was hab ich da eben aufgemacht, Code China, Chinesische China-Chinesen, ok, wir
schreiben schon mal nicht in die Memory-Stream, wir schreiben schon mal in der Ass, what,
warum haben die da nicht einfach ein Beispiel für Stream, wenn ich jetzt noch wüsste,
wie ich das mal, ich hab das letztes Jahr selbst gemacht, ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich
guck jetzt, ich guck jetzt, Samples, ich guck jetzt gleich in meinen eigenen Docs, ich guck
jetzt gleich in meinen eigenen Stream rein, so, wann war das, hier, ich guck jetzt in
meinen eigenen Stream rein, N-Audio, hier, das war Stream 20.12.2018, easy, 20.12.2018,
jawoll, siehste, so muss das sein, so, Maxception, so, hier, Streams, Streams disappear, ok,
hier versuche ich den Kram abzuspielen, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich da treibe, Audio
Bites, ok, KZFPS ist am Start, das ist glaube ich noch nicht das Abspielen, das ist noch
nicht das Abspielen, das Abspielen kommt dann später, ja, ach ne, hier versuche ich
noch rauszubekommen wie man das, ach hier, hier, da war es, Add Samples, ja, was hab
hier, Add Samples, Wave Format, Buffered Wave Provider, das Proma, siehste, Poggers, also,
ganze Mist, wieder weg, ja, Proma alles nett, oh, Output gleich New, Buffered Wave Provider,
Format, ach so, was hab ich denn da für ein Format angegeben, Wave Format, Create, ok,
Wave Format, Create, was, was soll ich createn, Sample Rate, 1100, Channels, klar, 16, so,
was muss man sonst noch machen, ja, Buffer Duration, das ist ok, 2 Sekunden klingt mir
sinnvoll, Discard on Overflow, ok, das klingt auch sinnvoll, Discard on Overflow, Output,
das können wir erstmal weglassen, Output, was hab ich noch gesagt, Buffer Duration,
ok, Timespan, Prom, Seconds, 2, ok, so, und wie spiel ich das jetzt ab, hier, New Wave
Out, Init, und dann Play, und das war's, New Wave Out, Latency, 100 Millisekunden kann ich
mitleben, so, und jetzt muss man den Input noch setzen, Init, ok, wir müssen den Output
als Input setzen, ok, alles klar, klingt logisch, und jetzt einfach sagen Play, Play, und New,
was, erst das, achso, ja, Add, nee, das war das andere, Output, Add Samples, Buffer, Offset,
0, 0, Count, was muss ich da reinschreiben, ah, Max, zeig, zeig, zeig, was hast du gemacht,
Count 4 oder so war das immer, achso, To Array, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob da jetzt was Sinnvolles
rauskommt, Bad Wave, Wave Bad Format, ok, New Wave Format, Rate, Bits, Channels, achso,
ich hab 16 Channels anstatt, Moment, 16 Channels, Keg-Wade, ja, das ergibt ja auch keinen Sinn,
2 Channels, 16 Bits, 16 Channels, easy, der Channel Champ, oh, habt ihr gehört, es hat
geknackst, habt ihr es kurz gehört, es hat geknackst, das klingt schon mal gut, aber
es spielt keinen Sound ab, das liegt jetzt aber hier dran, so müsste das dann funktionieren,
ok, da schreibt, Moment, da schreibt er Sachen rein, ohne, ohne, dass ich warte, das kann
er nicht, das kann er eigentlich nicht funktionieren, achso, ja gut, jetzt hab ich das Problem,
jetzt muss ich natürlich, oh ne, jetzt muss ich ja auch noch Timing-Geschichten machen,
da hab ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf, ne, das mach ich heute nicht mehr, kein Timing-Champ,
aber der spielt auch nichts ab, so als wäre das hier nicht das Richtige, ok, aber zumindest,
wir haben es schon mal gebracht dazu, dass es knackst, immerhin, ok, also wir haben gelernt,
wie man Audio auslesen kann aus einer Videodatei, bloß das Abspielen klappt noch nicht, was
wir mal gucken können, vielleicht ist der Sound wirklich einfach zu gering, aber das
glaube ich nicht, da spielt nichts, das will man sofort hören, wenn es funktioniert, ich
weiß gar nicht, ob wir 16 Channels haben, das schau ich schon nochmal schnell hier,
FF Probe, haben wir 16 Channels, mehr haben, äh, was sag ich denn, 16, ja wie viel haben
wir denn, wie viel Bit, man weiß es nicht, ich glaube 16, das dürfte so Standard sein,
gut, warum es nicht funktioniert, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, es kann auch sein,
dass das, was ich hier an Daten auslese schlicht und ergreifend verkehrt ist, passt das mit
der Rate 4410, äh, ich bilde mir schon ein, dass ich das, oder Kontext Sample Rate, Sample
Rate ist 4410, ja, ich mein, ich könnte es einfach so machen, also ich lese, also es
gibt zwei Varianten entweder, also erstens, meine Timings sind auf jeden Fall verkehrt,
die stimmen so auf gar keinen Fall und es kann auch sein, dass ich das falsch auslese,
woher weiß ich überhaupt, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, ich muss dem noch sagen, welchen
Channel ich outputte, guck mal, ich schreib hier aktuell beide Channel in, in den gleichen
Output, ich, wie kann ich dem denn sagen, welcher, welcher Channel das, das ist jetzt,
hm, ach, keine Ahnung, Leute, das mach ich schon immer, das, das ist mir zu, da bin ich
jetzt zu low-brain für, jetzt ist Wupp, Wupp, Bedgetime, da wird's ein extra neues Emote
dafür, komm, brauchen wir Outro-Musik, also Leute, wir sehen uns, ziemliches Rumgewurschtl
heute, hat nicht so ganz funktioniert, aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich bin grad so auf Streamstreak,
das, ich komm heute nochmal an, ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen, bis denn, wir sehen uns,
see you!
tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss!
tschüss, tschüss!
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.